COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES COMPLIANCE WITH THESE
ORDERS THE SENATE AS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND YOU KNOW THERE'S NO
MORE WINNING. OUR COMMITTEE
MEETINGS YOU HAVE TO GIVE THE
ADVICE MENSEN SO THAT'S WHY WE
WERE WAITING TO MAKE SURE I HAD
THE ADVISEMENT. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OR IS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN SIX
TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
MEET YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THIS TIME
YOU WILL BE I NEEDED AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND- AND ARE
VERY GLAD YOU YOU'RE CHOOSING TO
JOIN US TODAY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND INDEED ANY
INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED AND
I MUST SAY THAT- I'VE NEVER HAD
TO DO THAT I DON'T EXPECT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO THAT TODAY
BUT- THAT. THAT IS THAT THE
RULES THAT WERE WORKING UNDER.
WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WITH NO ITEMS PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS WE
NEED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS CAPITO HERE CABALLERO
PRESENT NIELSEN DOESN'T. NIELSEN
PRESIDENT DORADO. HERTZBERG
PRESIDENT WIENER. YOU HAVE A
QUORUM AKORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED NOW WE'D LIKE TO
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR
AUTHOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WELCOME SENATOR
DODD YOU MAY PRESENT ON YOUR
BILL SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEDICARE. GET
MEMBERS SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO WOULD
AUTHORIZE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
FORM COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
FINANCING DISTRICTS. TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE AT THE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL LEVEL. LET ME BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT TO SHOWN
IN THE S. B. EIGHT FIFTY TO MOCK
UP DISTRIBUTED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I ALSO WANTED TO THANK
THE CONSULTANT FOR HIS EFFORTS
ON THIS BILL. WE ARE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THE EXISTENTIAL
THREATS POSED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND I NEED NOT DESCRIBE THE
PROBLEM YET AGAIN. FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE STATE HAS
RESPONDED TO CLIMATE CHANGE BY
APPROPRIATING BILLIONS. TO FIND
A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS THAT SEEK
TO PREVENT AND PROTECT OUR STATE
FROM CLIMATE CHANGE DISASTER.
STATE PROGRAMS ADDRESS A BROAD
RANGE OF ISSUES ACROSS THE OLD
STATE LANDSCAPE HOWEVER THERE
ARE DIFFERENT RISKS POSED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT AFFECTS A
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES IN VERY
DIFFERENT WAYS. IN SOME
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS WHAT I
REPRESENT THE THREAT OF WILDFIRE
IS OF PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE IN
SOME COMMUNITIES THE MOST
SERIOUS THREAT FROM. RESULTS
FROM SEA LEVEL RISE IN YET
ANOTHER COMMUNITIES EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS POSE THE GREATEST DANGER
. SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO WILL
PROVIDE LOCAL COMMUNITIES WITH
ANOTHER TOOL TO PUT THEIR TOOL
KITS TO HELP COPE WITH AND
PREVENT CLIMATE RELATED
DISASTERS THAT ARE MOST CRITICAL
TO THEM. ASSEMBLY EIGHT FIFTY
TWO PERMITS CITIES COUNTIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO WORK AS A
JOINT ENDEAVOR TO DEVELOP PLANS
TO ADDRESS THE HIGHEST LOCAL
CLIMATE CHANGE PRIORITIES AND
GENERATE REVENUE TO IMPLEMENT
THOSE PLANS. THE FINANCING
MECHANISMS EMBODIED IN THE BILL
ALREADY EXISTED LAW SUCH AS TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING AND VOTER
APPROVED PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS. I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE EACH ONE
OF THE REVENUE RAISING
MECHANISMS IN SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO
ARE AVAILABLE TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACTING INDIVIDUALLY
NOW. UNDER SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO
THOSE SAME MECHANISMS WILL ALSO
BE AVAILABLE TO LOCAL ENTITIES
WORKING TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE FINANCING DISTRICTS.
BECAUSE SOME CLIMATE CHANGE
PROBLEMS ARE BETTER ADDRESSED
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES WORK
COLLABORATIVELY. NOTHING IN THIS
BILL MANDATES FORMATION OF A
DISTRICT AND NOTHING THIS BILL
CHANGES THE CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR VOTER APPROVAL
AND PUBLIC PARTICIPATION WERE
VOTER APPROVAL AND PARTICIPATION
ARE NOW REQUIRED. WITH ME TODAY
ARE FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROGER
DICKINSON WHO NOW SERVES AS THE
POLICY DIRECTOR OF CIVIC WELL
ADD MIKE PETERSON DEPUTY
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER FOR
CLIMATE AND SUSTAINABILITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GOOD
TO SEE YOU BACK. AND AT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FIRST OF ALL I'M I'M ROGER
DICKINSON POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
CIVIC WELL PREVIOUSLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION AND ONE OF
THE SPONSORS OF SB EIGHT FIFTY
TWO SENATOR ODD HAS DESCRIBED
THE BILL WELL AND WE THANK HIM
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. SB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO IS DESIGNED TO
ACCOMPLISH SEVERAL OBJECTIVES
INCLUDING THE FOLLOWING FIRST
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
REGIONS WITH THE ABILITY ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS TO PUT THE
SPOTLIGHT ON CLIMATE ACTION AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL SECOND PROVIDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND REGIONS
THE STRUCTURAL MEANS TO WORK ON
CLIMATE AND SUSTAINED CERTAIN
AND PREDICTABLE MANNER. THIRD
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OPTIMIZE
LOCAL STATE FEDERAL AND PRIVATE
RESOURCES TO MEET CLIMATE
CHALLENGES MOST IMPORTANT TO
THEIR COMMUNITY FOURTH GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FLEXIBILITY IN
ADOPTING THE RIGHT FINANCING
APPROACH FOR THEIR NEEDS AND
THEIR COMMUNITY AND FIFTH GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND REGIONS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS IN THEIR
LOCALITY. WHILE THE STATE HAS
ENACTED PROGRAMS AND MADE
INVESTMENTS TO MEET THE
INCREASING URGENCY OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN RECENT
STEPS TO ALSO DO SO FAR LESS
ATTENTION HAS BEEN PAID TO
DEVELOPING A COHESIVE AND
COORDINATED APPROACH AT THE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEVEL. AS THE
GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE ADAPTATION
STRATEGY RELEASED EARLIER THIS
WEEK NOTED PARTNERSHIPS
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
IN OUR EFFORTS TO BUILD CLIMATE
RESILIENCE ARE ESSENTIAL GIVEN
THE DIVERSITY OF THREATS
CALIFORNIA FACES IN THE VAST
ARRAY OF ENTITIES THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON BUILDING OUR
RESILIENCE TO THESE THREATS. ALL
ENTITIES FROM INDIVIDUALS TO
TRIBAL LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR HOLD A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE AND MUST WORK TOGETHER TO
LEVERAGE EACH OTHER'S STRENGTHS
AND ACTIONS IN RESPONSE. TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WE'D LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO MIKE PETERSON WHO IS ON
THE LINE HE'S FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. WELCOME. THANK YOU
BOB GOOD MORNING SHERRY
CABALLERO FHA NIELSEN AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MICHAEL PETERSON DEF YOU
COMMISSIONER ON CLIMATE IN
ABILITY HERE ON BEHALF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. ADULT SPONSOR
COMMISSIONER LARA WOULD LIKE TO
THANK CENTER DOCTORS LEADERSHIP
IN OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
CLIMATE RESILIENT THE MEASURE.
IN JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE RELEASED THE CLIMB IS
RENTS REPORT. TITLED PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES PRESERVING NATURE
AND BUILDING RESILIENCY. OUR
FIRST O ITS KIND CLIMB
INSURANCE. WILL HELP COMBAT THE
COSTS OF WILDFIRES EXTREME HEAT
AND FOUGHT. WHAT WAS THE WORK OF
CLANNISH WORKING GROUP CONVENED
BY FISHER LAW TWENTY. AND
COMPRISES OF ENVIRONMENTAL.
RESEARCHERS AND INSURANCE
EXPERTS. AND A PRESENTED FORTY
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM VARIOUS
POLICY TO REDUCE THE COSTS FROM
WILDFIRES EXTREME HEAT FLOODING
AMONG OTHER CLIMATE CHALLENGES.
A STRONG MESSAGE COMING OUT OF
THE CLUB INSURANCE REPORT WITH
AN ORDER TO IMPROVE INSURANCE
AVAILABILITY RELIABILITY. AND
AFFORDABILITY CALIFORNIA NEEDS
COMMUNITY MITIGATION TO IMPROVE
DRAMATICALLY. FURTHERMORE THE
WORKING GROUP EMPHASIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF LOCALIZED REDID
AFTER MITIGATION FOCUSES ON
WETLANDS FOREST MANAGEMENT AND
URBAN FOREST. IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF WILDFIRES SEVERE
STORMS FLOODING HE'LL RISE AND
EXTREME HEAT. AND THAT THEY
RECOMMENDED THAT THE COULD THERE
IS BE THE CREATION OF SPECIAL
CLIMATE RESILIENCY DISTRICTS TO
FOCUSED ON THE CLIMATE POLLUTION
. HI THE HAZARDS JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES. BECAUSE OF THAT. YOU
HAVE HEARD ABOUT THE DRESS
HOLISTICALLY AT THE REGIONAL
COMMUNITY AND LANDSCAPE SCALE
RATHER THAN PIECEMEAL
JURISDICTION BY JURISDICTION. SB
EIGHT FIFTY TWO WITH OVER TWO
BEARS THE CLIMATE ADAPTATION
FIRST THE NEED FOR FINANCING AND
ALSO THE IMPORTANCE OF CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL COLLABORATION. IT
IS ONE MAJOR STEP TOWARD
REDUCING COMMUNITY WIDE RISKS
AND THEREBY IMPROVING INSURANCE
AVAILABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
ALLOWING THESE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE DISTRICTS AND THEIR
CORRESPONDING MITIGATION PROJECT
. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS ME
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIRS AND ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD
BOB. OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
LISTED SO- WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO- TESTIMONY. IN SUPPORT.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT SO IT- IS
THERE ANYONE IS ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TEST FRIENDS FOR PLEASE
COME FORWARD. THANK HER THANK
YOU LONG. TERM MEMBERS SAID
THANK YOU- LIKE TO THANK. NICK
ROMAN WE HAPPILY OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES I LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING OF HIS
LEADERSHIP FOR WORKING ON THIS
MEASURES AS WELL AS THE
SPONSORS. ARE SINCE THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING HARD TO FIND
WAYS TO DO A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND IN OUR CITIES WE
WANT TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR-
THROUGHOUT THE SESSION TO GET
THIS DONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AGAIN IT'S
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. RESIDE IN CORPUS
COMPILER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. VERY
GOOD SIR ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. SEAMEN WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE IS- MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
TO QUEUE UP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEDICARE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO I
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TO SB
EIGHT FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHEN FILED BY ZERO EIGHTEEN T.
AFTER YOUR QUICKLY GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AND THEN
PLACE IT BACK INTO THE QUEUE.
WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH FIND NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. TWENTY NINE. GO
AHEAD ONE WEEK. RIGHT. ALL THE
AWFUL OVER THE NEXT REGISTER-
SESSION OF S. B. EACH WHOLE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE
. WINDS SIX PLEASE CALL YOU ARE
OPEN. BY SIXTY SIX ONE MORE TRY
. I WILL MOVE THE ONE MAN SHARED
A LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AREN'T ABLE ANTI AT REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. PLEASE THANK YOU ONLINE
SEVENTY YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING RUNNING COULD BE A LOCAL
BAKERY STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD ACTION FUND
IN SUPPORT. IN HERE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE SIXTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MATT ROBINSON WAS SHOT YOUR
INTUITION OLDER IN LYING ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN MATTEO CITY
COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS- WE'RE A GPA THAT
DEALS WITH THE WATER QUALITY
PROGRAM IN SAN MATEO COUNTY ON
BEHALF OF OUR TWENTY CITIES IN
THE COUNTY- WE ACTUALLY OF A
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE FILE-
IN JUST THAT ARE ASKING THE
AUTHOR ATTENTION MOVING FORWARD
TO CONSIDER HAVING. JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES TO THE AGENCIES ARE
ALLOWED TO FOR ME DISTRICTS AS
WELL AS CONSIDERING STORM WATER
AND STORMWATER INFRASTRUCTURE-
IN THE ELIGIBLE PROJECT CHARGES
THOSE ARE WE'RE TURNING TO THAT
MORE AND MORE TO HELP MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS OF THE DROUGHT SO
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION
AND LOOK FOR THE BILL PASSING
TODAY. AGAIN I'M GONNA ASK YOU
TO STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION AND IDENTIFY SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. NEXT PLEASE. WE
WILL GO ONE FOUR. GO YEAH
CALTRAIN GORY CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. AND A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO SP
EIGHT FIVE TWO AM LINE SIXTY
THREE YOU ARE UP PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING CAPTAIN FREEMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. NO
FORMAL POSITION BUT THANK
OFFERING CONTINUED WORK WITH
THAT THE FIFTEEN. MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT. ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MEASURE
NUMBERS THAT SUPPORT LARGER WITH
THE CLASSIC DENTURE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR WE DID
THE EXACT THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
IN ROOM. TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN
OPPOSITION. HELLO CHEN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS VANESSA CHAVEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION IN THE
BILL. AT THAT TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PRESTON
YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO THE BILL AS IT
APPEARS IN PRINT TODAY THANK YOU
THE AUTHOR STAFF ON THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR LISTENING TO
OUR CONCERNS AND WE WILL RE
EVALUATE THE POSITION WHEN THE
MOMENT TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. SEEING NONE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHT FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
NOBODY ON THE PHONE. ALL RIGHTS
ARE DOING UP AT THIS. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR- BRING
THE MATER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THIRTY
NIELSEN. BUT I'M KIND OF CURIOUS
SOME OF THE LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVES AND LET'S BE
SPECIFIC BECAUSE WE WANT TO
NARROW WHO ANSWERS ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES THIS SEEMS TO NOW
ALL OF THEM BRING IN A WHOLE NEW
AUTHORITY. A WHOLE NEW DIMENSION
OF THE PROCESS. IT SEEMS THAT
THIS COULD BE HANDLED WITHIN THE
EXISTING STRUCTURES CAN YOU TELL
ME WHY THIS IS SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND IT DOES APPEAR TO
ME THAT COULD JUST COULD BE
DILATORY AND- LENGTHENING THE
PROCESS OF PROGRAMS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. AND I READING THAT WRONG-
LET ME ASSURE YOU YOU CAN EVEN
GO AHEAD AND GET THAT CENTERED
ON THE SECOND POINT ON HERE- AS
THERE WERE SOME CONCERNS OVER
THAT THE CHAIR HAD CONCERNS OVER
THAT AS WELL AS STAFF. YEAH THE-
THE AMENDMENTS SO WE'VE TAKEN
WILL ONLY ALLOW A CITY OR COUNTY
TO INITIATE THE C. R. D.
FORMATION. AND WE THOUGHTIT WAS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT. YOU KNOW
IN THERE AS WELL SO YOU DON'T.
SO THE YOUR FEARS- THAT YOU BUT
YOU PROFESSED- DO YOU KNOW DO
NOT COME TO FRUITION. AND SO
THIS WOULD BE CITIES AND
COUNTIES EITHER A WANTING TO
WORK TOGETHER THINKING THAT THIS
IS THE BEST WAY FORWARD. TO
ACHIEVE IT NEEDS- THAT MEANS THE
END FOR A SPECIFIC ISSUE THANK
YOU CENTER THANK YOU CENTER. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THAT
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE AMENDMENT SENATOR- I
THINK IT MAKES MAKES IT A
STRONGER BILL AND IT DOES TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE ISSUE
RAISED BY. SENATOR NELSON WHICH
IS IT CITIES AND COUNTIES NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER AND THERE'S A
PROCESS ALREADY IN PLACE- AND
COMBAT PROCESS ALLOWS- THE
FINANCING FOR SOME OF THESE. ARE
PROJECTS THAT MAY END UP COSTING
MONEY SO DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU TOOK- IS
THERE A MOTION- THERE IS A
MOTION YOU MAY CONCLUDE CENTER.
BY PER SHAPE THE DISCUSSION THIS
MORNING I ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH C. SACK IN THE
CHAMBER. TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNSIF THEY HAVE ANY AFTER
THEY'VE SEEN THE- RESPECTIVE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREVER
. GOOD THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN
AYE NIELSEN HI TORONTO. DROUGHT
SO HI HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI
WIENER. FOUR ZERO FOUR FOUR THAT
IN SUPPORT ZERO OPPOSED WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON AFTERWARDS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS. SENATOR REID CASKEY S.
B. EIGHT NINE SEVEN WELCOME GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
I'M PRESENTING SP EIGHT NINE
SEVEN I WANT TO START WITH
EXPLAINED THE TECHS OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH I AM
ACCEPTING TODAY THE TO CHEER IN
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT I WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR THE WORK THAT
DAY- HAVE DONE WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL- WE HEARD FROM OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION FROM THE FROM THE
BUILDING OFFICIALS IN WHICH ALL
SECTION ONE WE'RE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE LOCAL BUILDING CODES
WE'RE GONNA PUT IN LANGUAGE THAT
WILL SAY THAT THE CONSTRUCTION
OF AN ACCESSORY UNIT DWELLING
SHALL NOT CONSTITUTE A GROUP OUR
OCCUPANCY CHANGE. ON THE LOCAL
BUILDING CODES THAT WILL CLARIFY
FOR THE BUILDING OFFICIALS
WHETHER THAT WILL TAKE THEM OFF
THE OPPOSITION WILL FIND OUT
THAT PRETTY SOON BUT AT LEAST
IT'S CLEAR FINE WITH REGARD TO
THE HEIGHTS THAT MEANT  LOT OF
THE ATTENTION HAS BEEN ON THE
HEIGHT LIMIT APPRECIATED CHEERS-
INPUT HERE SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS WE'LL GET ALLOW WE'RE GOOD
THE TEXAS COULD GO BACK TO
SIXTEEN FEET WHICH IS WITH WHICH
IT IS RIGHT NOW BUT WE'LL GET
ALLOW IF YOU WITHIN A HALF MILE
OF WALKING DISTANCE FROM MAJOR A
TRANSIT STOP YOU GET THE TWENTY
FIVE FOOT- LIMIT AND IF YOU HAVE
AN ATTACHED EIGHTY YOU TO YOUR
PRIMARY. RESIDENCE YOU GET THE
ATTACHED A TWENTY FIVE FOOT
HEIGHT LIMIT SO THAT WILL NARROW
THE BILL ALLOWS SOME OBVIOUSLY
SOMEBODY ELSE WILL COME IN AND
FINALLY ON THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE WE PUT THAT IN THE FIRST
EIGHTY YOU BILL THAT I DID- THIS
SECTION SHALL NOT APPLY TO
BUILDING THAT'S BEEN DEEMED
SUBSTANDARD TO ARE PUTTING THE
SUB STANDARD LANGUAGE IN THERE
WHICH AGAIN NARROWS THE BILL BUT
ACTUALLY. YOU KNOW HELPS FOR
MORE OF THESE EXISTING EIGHTY
USED TO GET LEGALIZED SO THAT
THAT THAT THE PEOPLE THAT PEOPLE
FEEL THE COMFORT I MEAN AS A
STAFF REPORT POINTS. OUT AND
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET SECOND
YOU IT'S A RIGHT WE HAD A BILL
AND THOUSAND TWO AND WHAT WE
FOUND OUT IS THAT ALL THE CITIES
HAVE MADE ORDINANCES THAT MADE.
POSSIBLE OR ECONOMICALLY.
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO BUILD
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAD FORTY
YEARS OF BASICALLY UNPERMITTED
UNITS TO COMMAND SO THIS BILL.
BUILDS ON THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE LEGISLATURE OVER THE
NEXT SIX. LAST SIX YEARS AND
REALLY REMOVES BARRIERS AND IN
MY OPINION UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR. FOR
EIGHTY YOU CONSTRUCTION MUCH OF
THE BILL. MOST OF IT IS FEEDBACK
THAT I'VE GOTTEN FOR THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT HAVE
GOTTEN FROM INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OR OTHER CITIES THAT
ARE STILL FACING SOME BARRIERS
THAT SUPPRESS EIGHTY YOU.
CONSTRUCTION SO THIS IS GOOD
ALLOW HOMEOWNERS TO MAKE BETTER
USE OF THEIR PROPERTY PROVIDE
FOR ADDITIONAL AND GENERALLY.
MORE AFFORDABLE RENTAL
AVAILABILITY IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE FOR
WEALTH BUILDING AND WE TALK
ABOUT WEALTH BUILDING BUT REALLY
SOME OF THE- PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY. TO DO IT OR
THEY JUST DON'T EXIST AND
THERE'S A PROVISION THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE STATE TO GET INTO THE-
BUSINESS OF GIVING PEOPLE SOME
GRANTS BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE ARE.
YOU KNOW A THIRD OF OUR
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME PEOPLE ARE
HOMEOWNERS WE FORGET ABOUT THAT
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT RENTER'S
BUT WE FORGET THAT THERE ARE
HOMEOWNERS THAT ARE EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME. THAT HAVE EXTENDED
FAMILIES WERE OPPORTUNITIES TO
BUILD WEALTH- IN ADDITION- TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF AN
UNPERMITTED EIGHTY USED AS
AMENDED THE BILL WILL PROVIDE
THE LOCAL WILL PROHIBIT A LOCAL
AGENCY FROM DENYING A PERMIT-
FROM THESE UNPERMITTED EIGHTY
USE THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT'S ANOTHER
AMENDMENT TO SAID I REALIZE IT
IS WE PASS THESE BILLS EIGHT
PEOPLE COULD ACTUALLY GO IN AND
BUILD A NON PERMIT UNIT AND COME
BACK AND ASK FOR FORGIVENESS
WE'RE GOING TO PUT A STOP IN A
WHICH IS SORT OF WHAT. ALL THE
LEGACY AND PERMITTED UNITS FOR
THEIR END BY DRESSING THESE
BARRIERS OUR HOPE IS THAT WE'RE
NOT ONLY GETTING COURAGE
HOMEOWNERS TO ASSIST US IN
DEALING WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS
BUT WE'RE GOOD ALLOW HOMEOWNERS
TO CREATE MORE FINANCIALLY STATE
MORE FINANCIAL STABILITY FOR
THEMSELVES IN WITH ME I HAVE
KELLY FALLON WHICH IS WITH THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL. AND I WOULD
URGE AND I FELT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ALLEN IS ON THE PHONE SO-
YOU MAY TESTIFY. HELLO TERRY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ALAMEDA
COUNTY'S CALENDAR. MANAGER GARY
KOPEL WHICH IS A PUBLIC POLICY
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE. IT IS NOT
WORKING THE SOUTHERN REGIONS
MUST CHALLENGING ISSUES THEIR
PROMPT BONTA E. NINETY SEVEN
WHICH HE SAID TRACTOR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES.
INITIAL THERE THAT WOULD MEAN
FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP. HOUSING
CRISIS IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
TO THEIR EMPLOYER SINCE A LACK
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS
AFFECTED AREAS ABILITY TO
ATTRACT TRYING AND RETAIN
OFFICIALS TO MAINTAIN LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY IN HOPE OF OUR
ECONOMY PROJECTED ISSUES VERY
HELPFUL SPONSORED BY ONE OF THE
FIRST MAJOR STATEREFORMS TO
EITHER PROCESS IF YOU. IN
THOUSAND SIXTEEN LISTENER CASKEY
AND NOT THE L. A. COUNTRY NINE
REDUCED REQUIRE TO CURRENT AND
OTHER- ON THAT PROVISION CAN BE
BUILT USED PEOPLE FOR MANY. SB
COUNTRY I BECAME THIS BECAUSE
MEMBERS OF YOU THE PROCESS TO
USE ANY OUR COUNTRY A LOT OF ALL
VERSIONS BUILDINGS STATE. IN
EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY ONE PER
INCREASE. ALSO NOTABLE THAT THIS
IS A ONLY TYPE OF HOUSING
EXTREME INCREASED APPROACH IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENT. NOW IS THE
SEVEN BUILT ON THIS BY CURRENTLY
. OWNERSHIP CHOIRMASTER THESE
EXTENDING A STATE JUNIOR AB IS.
WHICH IS A CRUCIAL ASPECT AND TO
GET IT'S FOUR BY THE OF FAMILY
OR IN NEED. WHAT THE RENTED OUT
SOMEONE OUR INCOME. WE'VE HEARD
STORIES RECENTLY FROM HOMEOWNERS
EIGHTY RENTER'S HAVING OPTIONS.
TO CARE FOR OTHER OR HOW DOES
SHE GENERATE EXTRA INCOME.
ESPECIALLY UNDER TIMES AND JUST
BEEN RECENT- EXTREME WITH THE CO
. AND LIKE IT'S REALLY ABOUT.
THIS WE ARE SEEING THE GREAT FOR
A TO USE A VARIETY AFFORDABLE
RENTAL ON CAN HELP. BUT ALSO
GENERATE HOMEOWNERS SO WE REALLY
HOPE TO SEE WILL CONTINUE ONE
SIX OF THIS ALL. LABEL TRACK OUR
- ARE STRICTLY ON ITEM YOU FOR
THAT TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. WE'RE GOING
TO SEE IF THERE'S WHO IN ROOM
TWENTY HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ANY INTO THING THEN WE'LL GO THE
TELL. LINE.
SB EIGHT NINETY SEVEN WILL BEGIN
WITHOUT MINE THIRTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. THAT GOES IN YOUR CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. FIND SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT I'M
SURE THIS IS BOB NAYLOR-
REPRESENTING PEOPLE SEVEN
COMPANY- OWNED BY HOWARD
AHMANSON JUNIOR INTO THE SIX
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY USE AND THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. FIVE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS IRA BELGRADE
FOUNDER OF YOU'D BE LA BOB AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT- ETCETERA
CASKEY SELF BILL S. B. THANK
YOU. NEXT NEXT IS ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS
GREG HAYES ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIVE TWO. I
THINK YOU HAVE THE RUN THERE
WERE THIS IS THAT'S THE WRONG
BILL. WE'RE ON EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN BUT WHAT WILL TAKE THAT
TEST PREHEATED I APOLOGIZE I
MEANT EIGHT NINETY SEVEN OKAY.
GLAD WE CLEARED THAT UP CLICK
HERE ALIVE YEAH IT IS IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT NINETY SEVEN OF AB
ABOUT THE ACTION COALITION
APOLOGIES NO PROBLEM YOU MADE
CENTER RIGHT HUSKY VERY HAPPY.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
IF YOU MEDICARE. LINE FIFTY
NINE. FIFTY NINE PLEASE ON MUTE. FIFTY NINE ONE MORE SHOT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO- TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR SB EIGHT NINE SEVEN. WELL
BEING ALONG OVER LIKE FIFTY ONE
YOU ARE OPEN. HI THERE MY NAME
IS RYAN ENJOY- CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIAN BE SUPPORT AND
THE CELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I AM SURE THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS CUED UP
THIS TIME. GOOD NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
BRANDY GIRTON GIRTON- CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS AND JASON
RYAN WHO IS HERE I BELIEVE IN IN
THE ROOM FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES SO WE'LL START
WITH JASON. IS THE CENTER OF
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JASON RYAN
LEE CALIFORNIA CITIES. WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE AND RESPECT
THE CENTERS-YOU KNOW TENACITY
AROUND EIGHTY USE AND WE'VE SEEN
A LOT CHANGE EVERY YEAR FOR THE
PAST SIX YEARS- THERE'S NO
DENYING THAT THROUGH HIS EFFORTS
WE'VE SEEN A PROLIFERATION OF
EDUS. AND MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES I'M EMBRACE
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS AND
BECAUSE IT IS A WAY TO YOU KNOW
GET GREATER DENSITY IN YOUR
COMMUNITY AND DO IT IN A WAY
THAT THAT IS. LESS INTRUSIVE
THAN WHAT OTHERWISE MIGHT BE-
APPRECIATE THE AMENDED ON
REDUCING THE HEIGHT YOU KNOW
WITH AND MOST OF THE NEIGHBORS
BUT A TWENTY FIVE FOOT HEIGHT IS
STILL A REALLY LARGE HEIGHT
PARTICULAR AREAS THAT HAVE. YOU
KNOW A HEIGHT LIMITATION OF A
SINGLE STORY HOME- IT MAKES YOU
REALLY WONDER WHAT. ARE THESE AN
ACCESSORY TO RATE I THINK WE'RE
GETTING AWAY FROM THE NOTION OF
THESE ARE SMALLER GRANNY FLATS
YOU ACCESSORY IN ITS AND THAT IN
FACT THESE ARE REALLY TWELVE
HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT TWO STORY
HOMES. THAT ARE NOW GOING TO POP
UP IN SOMEBODY'S BACKYARD AND
WHILE THAT MIGHT BE OKAY I WAS
SOON SOME NEIGHBORS MIGHT YOU
KNOW- NOT LIKE IT SO MUCH IF
THEY BOUGHT A HOME THAT'S YOU
KNOW IN A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT HAS
A LOWER YOU KNOW HEIGHTS. AND
NOW WITH YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THESE
TWO STORIES UP STRUCTURES POP UP
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT. HOW TO
CONSIDER BUILDING CODES- YOU
KNOW SCALING THAT BACK TO WHAT
YOU MENTION I THINK IS IMPORTANT
WILL CERTAINLY WORK WITH OUR
FRIENDS OVER THE BUILDING CODE
OFFICIALS TO SEE. IF THAT MEANS
THEY'RE THEY'RE THE REQUIREMENTS
AND FINALLY THE LAST CONCERN
THAT REALLY REMAINS- IS ALLOWING
A TWO EIGHTY USED TO BE
CONSTRUCTED ON A PARCEL FREE
PROPOSED MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT. THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT MULTI
FAMILY DEVELOPMENT EVER BE
DEVELOPED SO YOU GET TO EXCESS
THREE DEAL DWELLING UNITS
ACCESSORY TO NOTHING BECAUSE THE
PRIMARY UNIT MAY HAVE NEVER BEEN
CONSTRUCTED. SO AGAIN WE'RE JUST
FEARFUL THAT IS GETTING US DOWN
A ROAD WHERE THESE ARE NO LONGER
ACCESSORY INTO THESE ARE FACTS
STANDALONE UNIT SO WE WOULD
CONTINUE WORKING YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
BRETT. BREEDING GARDEN IS. THE
PHONE IF YOU COULD OPEN HIS
LINE. YOUR WELCOME TO TED. GOOD
MORNING. MONETARY COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BRADY CURTAIN THE
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS SENATOR
MURKOWSKI DOCTORS AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF GOOD THING YOU
DIALOGUE ON SB NINE SEVEN HELLO
MUCH FOR THE FUTURE. ON THE MOST
RESPECT OPPOSE SPELLING OF
CURRENT DUE TO LIKE TAKE YOUR
FOR. WE APPRECIATE HE ADDED
AMENDMENTS FOR THE I THINK YOU
CHANGE BUT I DO WE STUFF SOME
CONCERN ARE GONNA TALK A ABOUT
POLITICALLY CONCERNED YEAH-
SPECIFICALLY IT WILL THESE
CHANGES THE CENTER SO FROM A
HIGHER ROOM FOR BUT SPEAKING ITS
OPEN AND EDUCATE OUR YOU USUALLY
REQUIRE FURTHER WOULD NOT FOR TO
GOALS FOR EXAMPLE A GARAGE WITH
THE DATA. OF THE YOU ARE E. AS
WELL THANK YOU REGULATION
COMPARE TO IN WORKS FAMILY UNITS
UNDER THIS OFF THE GROUND OR TO
BE CONVERTED TO AN EIGHTY OF
WOULD BE DIFFERENT OF TRIMMING
OF THE CORRECT ARGUMENT RATING
WHICH OF THE NOT AND CRITICAL
FIRE LIKE SPEAK OF THE GROWING
IN IT TO PROTECT SAFETY BUT
BUILDING MUST BE ABLE TO FERMENT
AND APPLY THE INTENDED USER
OCCUPANCY OF THE BUILDING
REPORTERS ALLOWED TO BECOME
AVAILABLE SPACE. IF THE ABILITY
TO FOURTEEN REGULATIONS REMOVES
THE PUBLIC COULD BE AT SEVERE
RISK RESULTING IN THE LOSS OF
LIFE HISTORICAL EXAMPLE THAT
COMES TO MIND IN CALIFORNIA IS
THE GHOST SHIP WAREHOUSE FIRE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH OCCURRED IN
POINT IN. OAKLAND CALIFORNIA. X.
YOUNG. YOUNG LIVES FROM THE
WORLD. HELLO MEMBERS WANT TO
EVEN FORCE. EVENTS HAPPEN IN A
RESIDENTIAL AREA PLEASE NOTE
THIS PHONE ITS CURRENT. COULD
ABOUT AND I BE A LOT. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR COMPANY. BECAUSE
TEMPLETON. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PROMISING WITH THE- OF ON THE
BILL. IN HOPES OF REMOVING OUR-
BUT THANK YOU. FOR YOUR HARD
WORK AND WILL LOOK FOR NEW
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
S. AND ROOM TWENTY TW HUNDRED.
SEEING NONE OF MR MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD- OPEN THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS UP FOR SB EIGHT NINE
SEVEN PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN PLACE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO
LINE THIRTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STATE MORTGAGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
OPPOSED FOR THE REASONS THAT
REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS THAT WE ASK
OF THE APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. FOR WORKING
WITH US IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF IN
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. EXCLUDABLE LINE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT I'M
SURE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER THANK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
SPECIFICALLY TO REMOVE THE
HEIGHT INCREASE WITHIN SINGLE
FAMILY RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. THANKS IS ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY NINE YOUR
OPERATORS. THIS IS TEMPORARY AND
I DIDN'T GET INTO THE OF SUPPORT
BECAUSE I WAS CUT OFF BUT I'M
I'M I'M A VOLUNTEER ARE AND WE
SUPPORT EIGHTY S. B. EIGHT NINE
SEVEN RESPONSE TO ALL THE
HOUSING PROBLEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR APPRECIAE YOUR COMMENT
NEXT PLEASE. AND IT IS. THANK
YOU I WILL GO TO LINE. EIGHTY
TWO. EIGHTY TWO I THINK YOU TOOK
YOURSELF OUT OF MUCOID AT ONE
ZERO AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT NINE SEVEN. EIGHTY THREE
YOU ARE OPEN. BY THE CONNECTION
WITH THE HOMEOWNER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND I'M ADAM SURE
NOBODY ELSE WAS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. GOOD WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE CENTER WE
NORTH- THANK YOU FOR SO I WENT-
WE HEARD THIS A COUPLE WEEKS
LAST WEEK I GUESS AND- TIME
FLIES. AND A HOUSING COMMITTEE
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR HIS LONGSTANDING LEADERSHIP
AROUND EIGHTY USE- GOING BACK
BEFORE I WAS IN THE SENATE WELL
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS. ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND ON THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WE WERE CONSIDERING
EARLY- LEGISLATION TWENTY
FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN OF THE BY
CENTER BY CAL SKI- TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHTY YOU LAWS
MEANINGFUL- AND THERE WAS A
COMPLETE AND UTTER MELTDOWN BY
LITTLE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE
CENTER BY CAL SKI WAS- CLOSING
LOOPHOLES THAT CITIES. LIKE MY
OWN HAD EXPLOITED FOR DECADES TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM BUILDING A
TO USE COMPLETE MELTDOWN- AND
THAT LAW THAT BILL PASSED. ON
SKY DID NOT FALL- AND THEN- OVER
TIME WE'VE HAD DO MORE MORE
LEGISLATION. TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLES THAT SOME CITIES NOT
ALL BUT SOME HAVE BEEN
EXPLOITING TO MAKE IT HARDER
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO PUT
EIGHTY USE- IN THEIR IN THEIR
HOMES AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR- WHO IS. SADLY TERMING
OUT THE END OF THIS YEAR AND
WE'RE GOING TO MISS HIM DEARLY
FOR MANY REASONS- BUT IS YOU
KNOW- TRYING TO- TAKE SOME OF
THE REMAINING ISSUES AND ADDRESS
THEM- SO THAT WE'RE NOT. PUTTING
CONDITIONS AND LIMITS ON EIGHTY
USE THAT MAKE IT HARD OR
IMPOSSIBLE TO BUILD THEM- YOU
KNOW. IT'S DISAPPOINTING TO ME
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM
SOME OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GROUPS- JUST UP IS JUST.
OPPOSITION IT CLAIMING WE LOVE A
TO USE WE LOVE EIGHTY YEARS
DON'T MAKE US BUILD. YOU KNOW
TALLER APARTMENT BUILDINGS WE
CAN TEST TO WITH THE TO USE
TRYING TO RELY ON YOU TO USE
EVEN IN THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT
SOMETIMES IN INAPPROPRIATE WAYS.
BUT THEN CONTINUING TO COME
FORWARD AND OF AN OPPOSING
EFFORTS. TO TRY TO MAKE THE EDU
PROGRAM- AS ROBUST AS POSSIBLE-
AND THE IDEA THAT THERE WOULD BE
A CONCERN THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE AN
EIGHTY YOU WITHOUT A PRIMARY
HOME I DON'T. I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN BUT IF IT DOES
WHO CARES. IT'S STILL A HOUSING. UNIT THAT SOMEONE CAN LIVE IN-
AND TO COMPARE THIS TO THE- TO
THE- THE WAREHOUSE FIRE TO GO TO
THE GROCERY BUYER IN OAKLAND.
I'M SORRY BUT THAT IS MORE THAN
A LITTLE BIT DRAMATIC. TALK
ABOUT EDIE YOU HEAR ABOUT ABOUT
A MASSIVE. DANGEROUS WAREHOUSE-
THAT WAS BUILT MANY MANY MANY
YEARS AGO. SO I YOU KNOW I THINK
IN THE END WE HEAR A LOT OF THIS
CONSTANT LIKE NIT PICKING
EXCUSES FOR WHY WE CAN'T DO
THIS- AND GOD FORBID YOU HAVE A
TWO STORY EIGHTY YOU. GOT FOR
BEDS AND I THANK THE CHAIR THE
CHAIR FOR HAVING HAD SOME
CONCERN BUT WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO COME TO A GOOD
COMPROMISE ON THIS BILL AROUND.
THE HEIGHT ISSUE- AND I THINK
IT'S A GOOD COMBINATION YOU KNOW
IN THE END I WISH SOME OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT GROUPS WOULD BE
MORE FOCUSED ON THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE LIVING IN THEIR CARS
THAT WE HAVE TEN PEOPLE FIFTEEN
PEOPLE LIVING IN ONE APARTMENT.
TOGETHER IN MANY PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA OVERCROWDING BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT AFFORD. TO HAVE TO
HOUSING FOR. YOU KNOW FOR TWO OR
THREE OR FOUR PEOPLE. I WHICH
WOULD FOCUS ON THAT. BUT THAT'S
A RESPONSIBILITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE. AS
OPPOSED TO. WE DON'T WANT A FEW
EXTRA FEET OF HIGH WE DON'T WANT
TO STORY EIGHTY USE YOU MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A TO YOU WITHOUT A-
SINGLE FAMILY HOME- YOU KNOW-
IT'S JUST VERY VERY FRUSTRATING
TO ME- I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD BILL AND HAPPY TO MOVE A-
MANAGER THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND YOU MAY WANT TO ADOPT THAT
IS YOUR CLOSING SENATOR.
HERTZBERG ON A MAKE MINE SHORT.
TWO THINGS I JUST WANTED FOR THE
RECORD TO SAY THAT IN THE LOS
ANGELES. YEP OF FIRST THING I
WANT TO GIVE CREDIT TO DENNIS
CARDOZA WHO IT IS THESE WERE
CALLED GRANNY FLATS WHEN HE DID
IT BACK IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
NEVER PASSED THOSE YOU NEVER
FORGET THE PEOPLE THAT CAME
BEFORE TO- THE SEVERAL VALLEYS
AND WILDLY SUCCESSFUL. IN TERMS
OF PROVIDING HOUSING MORE THAN
SIXTY OR 70% OF ALL THE EIGHTY
USED IN THE LA THAT EVENTUALLY
BEEN APPROVED AND BUILT OUR FROM
THE SERVER NO VALLEY AND THREE
CAN YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
HEIGHT RESTRICTION THE MEMBERS
THAT YOU TOOK. WITH THE YEARS WE
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT. YEAH SO
WELL I'M I'M SURE IT'S. SO WE'RE
GOING TO. STRIKE THE TWENTY FIVE
FEET THAT'S IN THERE. AND GO
BACK TO SIXTEEN STATEWIDE EXCEPT
IF YOU'RE- IT WITHIN HALF MILE
OF A MAJOR TRANSIT STOPS IF YOU
GOT FIXED RAIL. IF YOU'VE GOT
MAJOR BUS STOPS THEN YOU GET STE
WE ARE IN A HALF MILE YOU GET TO
GO UP TO TWENTY FIVE FEET. THE
SECOND IS THAT IF YOU HAVE AN
EIGHTY YOU THAT'S ATTACHED TO
YOUR HOUSE SO. YOU KNOW LIKE
PEOPLE HAVE SECOND STORIES ON
THEIR ON THEIR HOUSE IF IT'S
ATTACHED. THEN YOU GET TO YOU
GET TO GO TO A- TWENTY FIVE FEET
OR WHATEVER LOCAL ORDINANCES
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO. THE LOCAL
ORDINANCES TWENTY THREE TEN WHEN
I. GOING OVER BUT MOST OF THESE
ORDINANCE FOR THEIR- AND THAT'S END SO EVERYTHING ELSE
WILL. THE EXISTING WILL REMAIN
THE SAME. ANY MORE COMMENTS
SENATOR EYES OF- YES I AM I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF EIGHTY
USE I THINK IT'S A GREAT WAY OF
ADDRESSING ONE PORTION OF
HOUSING I'M I'M I HAVE TO CATCH
UP AND TALK TO FOLKS AND- IN MY
DISTRICT AND I HAVE THIS MIXED
OF FEELING OF NOT ON YOUR BILL
BUT JUST ON THE IMPACTS OF
EIGHTY USE WE HAVE THOSE WHO
HAVE COME FROM THE OUTSIDE YOU
KNOW. A BIG BUSINESSES THAT COME
IN AND BUY THE PROPERTY AND YOU
KNOW THEY'LL ATTACH AND- OR A
BUILDING EIGHTY YOU NOT ALWAYS
TO THE PART TO WHERE IT SHOULD
BE- AND YOU KNOW BRING IN A LOT
OF LOW INCOME PEOPLE TOOK TO
RENT THEM. AND THEN YOU HAVE.
THOSE WHO LIVE IN THE DISTRICT
IN THE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD ALSO
LOING TERM THEY REALLY BUILD
THEM HOWEVER THEY CAN PATCH IT
TOGETHER AND IT BECOMES THAT. SO
I GUESS I'M IM NOT QUITE SURE
HOW THIS ALL FITS IN WITH YOUR
BILLS RIGHT AND I'M I INTEND TO
GO BACK AND HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT- I JUST
WONDERING YOUR THOUGHTS ON. THAT
KIND OF IT AND IT'S LED TO
ENORMOUS OVERCROWDING- IN
CERTAIN PARTS SO JUST YOUR
THOUGHTS ON HOW THIS COULD FIT
IN AND HELP SO THERE'S A
PROVISION IN THE BILL THAT WILL
ALLOW THE HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THERE'S NO WE DON'T
MAKE ANY APPROPRIATION HERE. BUT
WE ALLOW PART OF THAT OF THE
CALL THE HOUSING BUNDLE THAT WE
HAVE THAT THAT EIGHTY USE WOULD
BE ALLOWED SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY HAVE TO WORK OUT IF
THEY DECIDE THAT THEY WANT TO
GIVE. GRANTS THE PEOPLE I MEAN I
THINK WE GENERALLY. PUT PEOPLE
IN A. B. C. D. GROUP YOU KNOW A
BEING I GOT CASH I GOT EQUITY I
GOT NO PROBLEM GET MY FINANCING.
B. IS EITHER HAVE A LOT OF
EQUITY I HAVE A LOT OF CASH SO I
CAN DO IT IT'S THE CND WERE
PEOPLE. ACTUALLY NEED THE-
STABILITY OF ADDITIONAL INCOME
OR VICKY SAID THEY HAVE MORE
PEOPLE LIVING ON THE PROPERTY
THAT AREN'T THEY DON'T. THEY
DON'T QUALIFY FOR THE FINANCING
YOU KNOW A LOT OF TIMES THE
BANKS WILL NOT GIVE YOU YOUR
EXPECTED- THREE FIVE REVENUE TO
YOU'RE GOING TO GET FROM FROM-
THE RED DAY WE SAY WE'VE GOT TO
BUILD IT BEFORE YOU CAN. WILL
GET THE RENT SO THAT THIS JUICE
. ASKED THE- HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO COME
UP WITH SOME IDEAS AND ALLOWS
FOR THE FUNDING FOR THE EIGHTY
YEARS IS NOT PROHIBITED NOW BUT
WE JUST. PUT IT IN THERE TO TACK
IT THAT THAT WILL GO IN SO.
THAT'S IN OUR- I WISH I WAS HERE
FOR ANOTHER TWO YEARS TO TACKLE
THAT. THAT PROBLEM BUT WE ARE
TRYING TO GET RID OF THOSE
THINGS BUT I THINK THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE GOING BECAUSE- IT IS THESE
HAVE BEEN BUILT IN. THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY ARE OPEN TO HIM
A COUNTY OR IN DOWNTOWN LA
PEOPLE SEE WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE
AND PEOPLE. REALIZE HOW THEY'VE
HE PROVIDED THAT CAN COME A
PROVIDED. THAT THE KIDS COMING.
COMING BACK- SEVEN. HIS WILL
MORE QUESTION. ON THE- ON THE M.
AMNESTY PARDON THAT THAT'S IF
YOU APPLY. TO BUILD UP OR
REBUILD IT WHAT WHAT IS THE
AMNESTY PEACE COME IN AS AN AND
IF AND IF YOU'RE BELOW THE YOU
KNOW THE PART WHERE YOU SHOULD
BE. ARE YOU. YOU KNOW HOW ARE
YOU TREATING YOURSELF IN BUT
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO DO AN
EXCHANGE AND THAT'S- THAT'S HAS
BEEN A CHALLENGE SO WE KNOW
THAT. THERE WERE. TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF EIGHTY USE BUILT
FROM THE SEVENTIES TILL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT NEVER GOT THE
PERMIT BECAUSE THEY WENT INTO
THE STATE THEY WILL WENT INTO
THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT WERE
TOLD THEY COULDN'T GET IT AND
PEOPLE DECIDED FOR WHATEVER
REASON THAT THEY WOULD BUILD IT.
THAT WAS NOT SUBSTANDARD HOUSING
WE DON'T KNOW BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE A PERMIT BUT MOST OF IT WAS
BUILT FOR THE CODE AT THE TIME
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE SAID
WE NEEDED A PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE
TO COME IN AS YOU SAID THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO. HAVE THREE SHUT
DOWN SO WE'VE LANDED ON OR WE
LANDED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ON
HEALTH AND SAFETY WHOSE LONG
ISSUE REACHED THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY THAT IT IN WHICH IS WHAT
HAPPENS NOW IF YOU BUILDING
INSPECTOR GOES INTO A RENTAL
UNIT BECAUSE- THE CITY OR
JURISDICTION. NORMALLY WHAT THEY
DO IS THEY LOOK AROUND OUT OF
WALLS PEELING DOWN THEY TAKE THE
THEIR GADGET AND PUT IT IN ONE
OF THE PLUGS TO SEE IF THE
ELECTRICITY IS GROUNDED IF IT'S
NOT GROUNDEDTHE SAY YOU GOT A
GROUNDOUT RIGHT SO THEY THEY DO
THAT BUT THEY DON'T. COME IN AND
RIP UP THE- THE WHOLE HOUSE
BECAUSE IT WAS BUILT. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND IT'S
FORTY HER IS ALSO AT NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO IT WAS IS THAT WE SO.
THAT'S THE PATHWAY AND WE'RE
HAVING WE'RE HAVING SOME SUCCESS
BECAUSE SOME. WE WANT THOSE. TO
BE LEGALIZED LEVINE PEOPLE ARE
LIVING IN THEM FOR WHATEVER
REASON SO WE DON'T. AND IN MY
YOU KNOW I DISAGREE WITH SOME OF
THE- ANALYSIS I THINK THAT ONCE
YOU LEGALIZE. THEN MAYBE YOU'LL
IMPROVE IT BECAUSE YOU CAN NOW.
ADVERTISES A LEGAL UNIT INSTEAD
OF HUSH HUSH HUSH. AND MAYBE YOU
CAN TAKE DOWN THE GARAGE DOOR
AND PUT IN A WINDOW AND A REAL
TO OUR RIGHT. AS LONG AS YOU'RE
AS LONG AS YOU PASS IT TOO SO
THERE'S FRICTION THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT THAT WHAT COMES FIRST
WE LET THE PEOPLE. GET LEGAL-
AND THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE SO
MUCH PRESSURE ON THE CITY'S AND
WE KNOW THERE'S SO MANY OF THESE
UNITS DOWN. THE THINKING IS
THAT. LEGALIZE THEM AND HAVE LET
THE CITY. ACCOUNT FOR THEM WITH
THE READING NUMBERS TO REACH THE
REGIONAL NUMBERS THAT THEY CAN'T
AND THEN WORK WITH THE
HOMEOWNERS TO. TO BRING UP THE
CALL THE LISTEN JUST LIKE YOU
WANT. NO I LIVE IN A SIXTY YEAR
OLD HOUSE A LOT OF MY NEIGHBORS
HAVE THE ORIGINAL WINDOWS. I'D
LIKE FOR THEM TO. IMPROVE WE ALL
WANT THAT SO THAT'S THE THEORY.
THE YOU. THING KNOWN FOR THE
QUESTIONS WE DO HAVE A PROMOTION
WILL ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE. I'LL
TAKE A CENTER WINNERS COMMENTS
IS MY CLOSE INTERACTION I'VE OF
A WISE MAN. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND IT
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS CAPITO
HI. HELLO HI NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN HI DURAZO. ROSEAU HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE WIENER
WIENER HI THANK YOU FIVE ZERO
FIVE ZERO WILL PUT THAT ON CALL.
SENATOR PENN. WELCOME THANK YOU
. AT THE END YES YOU MAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- SENATORS- FIRST
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING SO DILIGENTLY
WITH MY OFFICE AND STAKEHOLDERS
IN CRAFTING THE AMENDMENT
LANGUAGES OF THE FORCE ACCEPTING
THE MINUTES THE SECOND OUR
REGION IS- RIGHT HERE'S RATE AS
HAVING THE SECOND HIGHEST RISK
OF MAJOR FLOODING AMONG ALL
AMERICAN METROPOLITAN AREAS.
THAT'S WHY I'M OFFERING THIS
BILL SENATE BILL NINE OH ONE
WHICH WILL PROTECT WEST
SACRAMENTO RESIDENTS AND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FROM
FLOODING SPECIFICALLY THIS
MEASURE WILL CODIFY FEDERAL
ACTION IN STATE LAW I OBTAINED A
CURRENT AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
WEST SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD
CONTROL PROJECT THIS BILL ALSO
AFFIRMS THE ACTIONS OF THE LOCAL
YELLOW LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION TO CONSOLIDATE
OVERLAPPING FLOOD CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS UNDER A SINGLE
AGENCY TO IMPROVE THE
COORDINATION OF FLOOD CONTROL
EFFORTS. DELAYS STEMMING FROM
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAVE
STALLED STATE AUTHORIZATION
WHICH IS PREVENT THE PROJECT
FROM BEING ABLE TO ACCESS STATE
FUNDS YOU MUST ACT ACT
EXPEDITIOUSLY TO UPDATE PROJECT
AUTHORIZATION AND MEET THE STATE
MANDATED TWO HUNDRED YEAR LEVEL
OF FLOOD PROTECTION THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT'S ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES HAS THE
SUPPORT OF THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO THE WEST SACRAMENTO
AREA FLOOD CONTROL AGENCY
RECLAMATION DISTRICT NINE
HUNDRED THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES THE
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY AND
YELLOW COUNTY. HAS NO FOR
REGISTERED. OPPOSITION OR SPEAK
THE ASTRONAUT. GOOD WE HAVE TO.
WITHIN IN SUPPORT. OF BOTH OF
WHOM ARE ON THE PHONE AMY BROWN
FROM THE CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO
AND- GREG FIVE BALLOON WHO IS
ALSO FROM THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO. SACRAMENTO SO WE'LL
START WITH AMY ADAMS. YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AMY
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
WEST SACRAMENTO. WE WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR OFFERING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE AND WANT
TO REITERATE OUR THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
US OVER THE PAST MONTH. I WANT
TO QUICKLY STRESS WHAT'S CENTER
BAND I DID SAY IT OPENING
STATEMENT REGARDING THE DELAYS
WE'VE BEEN EXPERIENCING IN STATE
AUTHORIZATION FOR THIS PROJECT
YOU TO KOBE- IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WHAT SACRAMENTO PROJECT
MOVE. EXPEDITIOUSLY I THE
CONSTRUCTION OR WE FEAR THAT WEB
SACRAMENTO IN THE ENTIRE
SACRAMENTO RIVER FLOOD CONTROL
SYSTEM WILL REMAIN AT RISK. YES
ABOUT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT GREGA FOR BOONE. THE
MANAGER IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I THANK YOU FOR- BUT
A BILL THIS MORNINGMY NAME IS
GREG THEY'VE BEEN ON THE FLAT
GENERAL MANAGER FOR THE CITY BUT
SACRAMENTO AND ALSO. THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR THE WEST SACRAMENTO
AREA BUT PEOPLE AGENCY. I'M NOT
HERE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE- AND THAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
ASK WHAT I'VE OPENED WITH THAT
EITHER. THANK YOU. YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TO- WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE UP IT TO ME AND SEE IF
IT THERE'S ANYONE IN THE ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. THEY WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. SEEING NONE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. ANY
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO I TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE ZERO ONE THE FIRST
ONE FILED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FILED BY ZERO. MADAM CHAIR
WE WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY SEVEN
. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM THE
OPEN MARKET BEHALF OF YELLOW
COUNTY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
KNOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU AS A REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT S. B. NINE ZERO ONE.
MEDICARE NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP
THIS TIME. VERY GOOD WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED SO
LET ME CHECK AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO MOVEMENT
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE A ONE. DESPITE OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE OH ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE OH ONE.
I'M SURE NOBODY IS KILLING UP. A
GOOD WILL BRING THAT BILL BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I HEARD SENATOR
HERTZBERG WE COME UP MAKE A
MOTION THAT AND IS THAT CORRECT
IT IS- ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
YES SENATOR NIELSEN YES MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND HAVE TENER
PAN AYE H. AYE. POLDER SOFT
CONSENT BECAUSE I HAVE
REPRESENTED THIS AREA MANY YEARS
AGO AS I DID MOST OF ALL OF THE-
NORTH DELTA AND CENTRAL DELTA.
CANNOT CERTAINLY FAMILIAR WITH
THE VULNERABILITY OF THE- WEST
SACRAMENTO AND HIS WEALTH THE
THOMAS AREAS THAT WE'VE GOT TO
BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT. ONE
CONCERN IS THE- THE ROLE OF
LASKO. AT V. IN THE IN ANY WAY
COULD THIS BE. OF DIMINISHING
LIVE CLOSE RESPONSIBILITIES AND
AUTHORITIES AT ALL AND OR IS IT.
COMPLICATING THE PROCESS OF
GAINING APPROVALS THOSE TWO OR
FROM CONCERNED SENATORS SO
ACTUALLY- IN TWENTY NINETEEN
DEAL AFTER DETERMINED IT WOULD
BE BEST TO REORGANIZE
RECLAMATION DISTRICTS AND THE
FACT THIS BILL REAFFIRMS LEFT
GOES ACTIONS. AND IN FACT THE
IN- AND IN CONSULTATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS COUNCIL AND
COMMITTEE STAFF WE HAVE CRAFTED
LANGUAGE AFFIRMS BOTH THE ACTION
CONSOLIDATE THESE AREAS. SO YOU
KNOW WHY DIDN'T LAUGH COULD
CHANGE THE BOUNDARIES IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WELL ACTUALLY-
CERTAINLY THE CITY- AND RT YEAH-
RECLAMATION DISTRICT NINE
HUNDRED DID NOT DISPUTE THE LEFT
HAD THE AUTHORITY HOWEVER IS THE
PREFERENCE OF. THE RECLAMATION
DISTRICT COUNCIL TO HAVE SOME
MENTION OF THE BOUNDARIES IN
STATE LAW IN FACT THIS LANGUAGE
STRIKES THE BALANCE BETWEEN
CODIFYING LAUGH BECAUSE ACTIONS. OF STATE LAW AND AFFIRMING THE
AUTHORITY. AND WANT ONE THE
QUESTION THE- WOULD WOULD THIS
WOULD PERMIT THEN- YOU ANY
PROJECTS TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
STATE FUNDING NOW WITH A LOT OF
PROJECTS OF THIS NATURE THERE'S
A LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY DO WE
HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MUCH WAS
SACRAMENTO WAS INVESTED THUS FAR
IN THEIR- ACTION OF THEIR OWN.
OF COMING OUT FROM THE FLOODS
SO- ATUALLY MAYBE PERHAPS IT'S
BEST A QUESTION MIGHT BE BEST
ANSWERED BY EIGHT- BY ANY BROWN
TO REVERSE HIS HERE TO REPRESENT
THE CITY BY SACRAMENTO. THIS
BROWN PLEASE. YES I'M GONNA KICK
IT OVER TO- THE GENERAL- FUND
MANAGER GREG STATEMENT THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS IS
VERY GOOD AGAIN YEAH SO FAR ON
THE CITY OF WHAT SACRAMENTO AND
WITHOUT MERIT BUT PEOPLE LIKE TO
SEE- CONDUCTED OVER TWO HUNDRED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN ADVANCE
AND- THIS CALL PROJECT. THAT
WOULD APPEAR THE TO THE LOK
COMMUNITIES ON THEIR PART IN.
HISTORICALLY HAND I HOPE LESS
SACRAMENTO IS IMPROVING
ECONOMICALLY AND ALL MANNER I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH IT ANYMORE I
DON'T REPRESENT BUT THAT THAT
SAID THE LATCHES MY QUESTION
SATISFACTORILY AND- WILL BE
SUPPORTED TO BILLS AND RICHARD
PAN. THANK YOU FOR. THOSE
QUESTIONS- WE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS SAYING
NONE OF PLEASE THE MOTION IS
DEEP DO PASSED BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI TO ALSO. DO ALSO HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI WIENER.
WIENER HI. FIVE ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE BIGGER MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WILL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR CENTER
GROVE SB. TEN SEVENTY THREE. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SENATOR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THIRTY WILL GOOD
MORNING MISS MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
TEN SEVENTY THREE WHICHIS A
REINTRODUCTION OF LAST YEAR'S SB
SIX FIFTY EIGHT WHICH PASSED OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE FIVE ZERO.
THIS YEAR'S BILL IS ONCE AGAIN
SPONSORED BY SAMPOERNA DINO-
ASSESSOR RECORDER COUNTY CLERK
BOB DUTTON THE MEASURE
AUTHORIZED THE COUNTY ASSESSORS-
TOUGH OFFER A PARTIAL PROPERTY
TAX DEDUCTION FOR DISABLED
VETERANS PROPORTIONATE TO THEIR
PERCENTAGE OF DISABILITY RATING
. THAT'S PROVIDED BY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
FOR THE MILITARY SERVICE IN
WHICH THE VETERAN WAS DISCHARGED
OTHER STATES OFFER PROPERTY TAX
CREDITS IN VARYING DEGREES. AND
MANY OTHER MANY ALLOW VETERANS
TO QUALIFY WOULD DISABILITY
RATINGS LESS THAN 1100%
INCLUDING FLORIDA ILLINOIS AND
TEXAS. CURRENTLY DISABLED
VETERANS- MAY REQUEST A
REDUCTION ON THE THEIR HOMES
ASSESSED VALUE FOR THE PURPOSES
OF DIFFERENT TERMINATE PROPERTY
TAX IF THEY'RE 1100% DISABLED
BLIND IN BOTH EYES OR HAVE LOST.
TO WERE MORE LIMBS. IF TO SEIZE
THE VETERANS SURVIVING SPOUSE
MAY ALSO QUALIFY. HOWEVER
WITHOUT THIS BILL A VETERAN WITH
A LIFE CHANGING 50% DISABLED
GRADING WOULD CONTINUE TO BE AN
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROPERTY TAX
DEDUCTION ON THEIR DISABILITY
RATING. ALONE NEW DATA PROVIDED
BY THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS GAINED AN
ADDITIONAL TEN THOUSAND DISABLED
VETERANS. AND LESS WITH LESS
THAN 1100% DISABLED RATING SINCE
JUST AST YEAR THIS BRINGS THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF DISABLED
VETERANS TO MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND. WHO ARE INELIGIBLE FOR
OUR CURRENT STATE PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION. THE CALIFORNIA SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE REPORT FOR
TWENTY TWENTY IDENTIFIED
CALIFORNIA'S HAVING THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF VETERANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. ALMOST ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED IN ITS
ASSESSMENT IN THE COMMITTEE SHOW
THAT THE HOMELESS VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTED 31% OF
THE NATIONAL HOMELESS VETERAN
POPULATION. ADDITIONALLY
CALIFORNIA HAD THE HIGHEST RATE
OF AND SHELTERED VETERANS ALMOST
EIGHT THOUSAND IN THAT SAME YEAR
EXPERIENCED A THREE POINT 8%
OVERALL INCREASE IN VETERAN
HOMELESSNESS. SB TEN SEVENTY
THREE COULD BE THAT SAVING GRACE
FOR THAT VETERAN HELPING THEM TO
KEEP THEIR HOME AND GET THEM
THROUGH THE HARDSHIP UNTIL THEY
CAN GET BACK ON THEIR FEET.
THOUGH THOUGH THERE S NO AMOUNT
OF FINANCIAL BENEFIT THAT CAN
EQUAL THE AMOUNT OF LOSS THAT
VETERANS HEAD MAY FACE THIS BILL
EXPANDS ON THE ALREADY EXISTING
PROGRAM AIMED TO ASSIST.
CALIFORNIA'S DISABLED VETERANS
PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED RELIEF TO
STRUGGLING VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. ON THE PHONE WITH ME
TODAY IS FORMER STATE SENATOR
BOB DENTON. WHO IS IT ASSESSOR
RECORDER COUNTY CLERK FOR
SAMPOERNA DINO COUNTY. IN THIS
BILL SPONSORED AND AS WELL AS
SETH READ REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA VETERANS READ
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO FORMER SENATOR BOB DENTON
WELCOME. WELL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I AM THE AS A COUNTY
ASSESSOR PERCENT MEDINA COUNTY
WOULD GIVE ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
SPONSOR SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY
THREE. LEGISLATION THAT WAS
INTRODUCED BY SENATOR GROW. THAT
AMEND SECTION TWO OH FIVE POINT
FIVE IS REVENUE AND TAXATION
CODE. THE BILL TEN SEVENTY THREE
WOULD EXPAND ELIGIBILITY OF THE
DISABLED VETERANS EXEMPTION BY
ALLOWING THE COUNTY ASSESSOR. TO
APPLY A PARTIAL THIS IS
DISABILITY. VETERANS EXEMPTION
EQUAL TO THE PERCENTAGE OF THE
DISABILITY THE VETERAN IS RATED
. CURRENTLY THE DISABLED
VETERANS EXEMPTION IS AVAILABLE
ONLY- IF THE VETERAN IS 1100%
DISABLED. BE TOTALLY DISABLED
THAT MEANS THE VA. WILK THE VA
THEY DID OR THE MILITARY TO
DISCHARGE THE VETERAN WITH A
DISABILITY RATING OF A 100% DUE
TO AN INJURY HE SUSTAINED WAY
SERVING OUR COUNTRY. OVER TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND VETERANS RESIDE
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY WITH A
SERVICE CONNECTED DISABILITY
READING OF THOSE FOUR THOUSAND
VETERANS HAVE A ONE SO 1100%
DISABILITY RATING. THIS MEANS
THAT DISABLED VETERANS EXEMPTION
ONLY APPLIES 216% OF DISABLED
VETERANS OF SAMBAR DINO COUNTY.
YOU HAVE A VETERAN AS-
DISABILITY READING OF NINETY
PERCENT. CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
ALLOW THEM TO QUALIFY FOR THIS
EXEMPTION TOO OFTEN COUNTY SAYS
USER FOUR STRAIGHT AWAY.
DISABLED VETERANS SEEKING THIS
EXEMPTION SB TEN SEVENTY THREE
SEEKS TO HELP OUR DISABLED
VETERANS THE BILL WE ESTIMATED
THE STATE PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
WOULD BE REDUCED BY A HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. THE STATE ALREADY
COLLECTS MORE THAN SIXTY BILLION
IN PROPERTY TAXES THE HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR IF THAT WAS THE CASE
WITH ONLY A QUICK TWO POINT 3%
OF TOTAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
COLLECTED AMONG THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES OF THE STATE. IN THE
LAST DECADE KENNY ASSESSOR
ASSESSMENT TAX ROLLS HAVE GROWN
ON AVERAGE OF 5% PER YEAR. SO
IT'S NOT REALLY A LOSS YES YOU
WE YOU KNOW ABOUT THE POINT
THREE PERCENT- LIST PROPERTY TO
EXPOSE ALSO KEEP IN MIND TO NOT
ALL VETERANS. OWN HOMES. AND
THAT THE NUMBER WAS BASED. ON
LIKE A 100% FIGURE- WOULD SEEM
THAT WOULD BE. NOW WITH THE
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
SURPLUS THAT THE STATE CURRENTLY
IT HAS IT. IS THE LEAST WE CAN
DO TO KIND OF HELP ADD AN
ADDITIONAL BENEFIT. ONE OF THE
THINGS THE KELLY SAYS TO THE
REALLY- AND BOTHERS ME IS THAT
WILL HAVE THAT FRIENDS OF PLY
FOR THESE EXEMPTIONS AND THEN WE
HAVE THE YOU HAVE TO TELL THEM
THAT WELL BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
RATED A 100% THAT WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING FOR YOU AND THAT REALLY
IS BECAUSE IT REALLY BOTHERS ME
. I WOULD LIKE THANK SENATOR-
SHOWING GROVER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE- I
THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
SERVE PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES TO OUR NATION'S AND
DISABLED VETERANS. THEY'VE MADE
A GREAT SACRIFICE WAY SERVING
OUR COUNTRY AND ARE DESERVING OF
THIS BENEFIT. I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND I WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO SET
TO READ. WHO IS ALSO ON THE
PHONE. SHARES GOOD MORNING CARE
NUMBERS MY NAME IS SET TO READ
WITH THREE DIFFERENT RELATIONS.
I'M INFANTRY COMBAT VETERAN TO
THE POINT. I'M A DISABLED
VETERAN BUT LESS THAN 1100%
DISABILITY RATING UNFORTUNATELY
I DID NOT KNOW HOW THE
DISABILITY COMPENSATION PROCESS
WORKED AND EVEN THOUGH ALL MY
DISABILITIES COMBINE TODAY ARE
OVER A 100% IT IS UNLIKELY I
WILL EVER REACH THE ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. COMPENSATION Q. TO WHAT
IS VETERANS CALL BE A MATH FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE COMPENSATED
AT 60% DISABILITY AND FILE FOR
AN INCREASE OR NEW BENEFIT. AND
ARE GRANTED A 20% DISABILITY FOR
THAT NEW CLAIM OR INCREASED WE
WILL REMAIN AT THE 60% PAY SCALE
FOR YOUR DISABILITY. I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A CONFUSING
TOPIC SO I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
MEET WITH ANY MEMBER THAT MORE
IN DEPTH CONVERSATION IF NEEDED.
RECENTLY AT VA ANNOUNCED PLANS
TO UPDATE THEIR SCHEDULE FOR
RATING DISABILITIES THE
OFFICIALS SAY THE CHANGES LIKELY
WILL RESULT IN HIGHER DISABILITY
RATINGS FOR VETERANS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS BUT- YOU WERE
WEALTHY QUALIFYING FOR
DISABILITY COMPENSATIO.
COMPENSATION FOR SUCH THINGS AS. TITUS AND SLEEP APNEA. ACTION
RESULT INDEED. BENEFITS FOR SOME
FROM. YEAH REMOVE THEM THE BANK
BAKER RECEIVE. SB TEN THIRTY
THREE TEN MUCH NEEDED BENEFIT
FOR DISABLED VETERAN HOMEOWNERS
AND WOULD HELP ENCOURAGE. FIRST
TIME DISABLED VETERAN HOMEBUYERS
BIGGEST BENEFIT IS THAT THIS
BILL WOULD ACCOMPLISH BIGGEST
BENEFIT IN THIS BILL WOULD
ACCOMPLISH IS HELPING SOME
HOMELESS VETERANS GET INTO A
HOME. ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS
THE AMERICAN LEGION AND THAT'S
THE PART IN A CALIFORNIA COMPANY
ASSOCIATION COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDER SPECTRUM CANCEL
THE DEBT NUMBER ACTIONS OF
AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL. SUPPORT SB TEN SEVENTY
THREE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
AN IDOL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SIR AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO-
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO ADD ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WILL NOW GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE- MISTER
MODERATOR. IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SHE
TO SP TEN SEVENTY THREE. PLEASE
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY AND PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED
BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR SB. TEN SEVENTY THREE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. EVERYBODY ELSE
BUDGET ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THEY ARE WITH OUR PLAYERS
MANAGERS SHOULD BE WITH THIS ANY
SECOND. AND WE WERE LIKE FIFTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. YOU DIDN'T
USE. THIS IS FRANK MARCELLO.
OKAY I HAD MORNING THIS IS
MORNING THEN THIRD CHAIR THIS
IS- EMMANUEL MONTANEZ OKAY. YES
YOU MAY PROCEED. YES YES MA'AM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE TIME FREESHEET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THIS WITH
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AGAIN MY
NAME IS EMMANUEL MONTANEZ AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
REPRESENTING VETERANS STRONG USA
. I WAS- WOUNDED. THERE WERE
OTHER. I HATE TO DO THIS BUT
WE'RE WE HAVE RECEIVED THE TO-
TESTIMONIES IN SUPPORT IN OUR
WORK AT THE POINT WHERE WE'RE
JUST HAVING INDIVIDUALS IDENTIFY
WHO THEY ARE WHO THEY REPRESENT
AND WHETHER THEY'RE IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION I APOLOGIZE BUT
IT'S- WE HAVE A LONG HEARING
TODAY. OKAY I HAVE DIED AND I DO
THINK YOU KNOW YOUR A SINGLE
PARENT. OKAY NINE LIKE EMMANUEL
MARTINEZ UNITED STATES ARMY THAT
REPRESENTING THAT THAT'LL AND
STRONG U. S. DAM IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE IT.
NEXT PLEASE. I FIFTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN FOR ANYBODY ELSE UP
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TO SP TEN SEVENTY THREE ONLY TEN
SEVENTY THREE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. FIFTY FIVE YOUR OPEN. FOR ME BUT MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER SHERMAN ARMY AND NAVY
VETERAN MAYBE PERCENT DISABLED I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR
. NEXT PLEASE. AND WE DO HAVE
WON WITH AN OPERATOR AND THEY
JUST GOT CAUGHT UP OUTLINED
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARK
OF THE THIRD QUARTERS WITH
VETERANS ON YOUR SAID WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. AND ONE MORE DIGITS
QUEUE UP WITH AN OPERATOR ONE
MOMENT SURE THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR HOME
WILL BE A NON VETERANS AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS DEAL ALSO
WITH ACTION STRONG. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE IN YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. NEXT
PLEASE. AND I'M SURE THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO LISTED OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL SO WILK WELL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WANTS TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SAYING NONE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP INDIVIDUALS WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS. BILL THAT WOULD BE
TERRIFIC. OKAY DESPITE
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. I MEDICARE NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP VERY GOOD I'M GONNA
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AS ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS I NEED A
MOTION THE BILL. THERE IS THERE
IS A MOTION- MISS GROVE YOU MAY
COULD I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR- THAT. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AND
I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS I DON'T REMEMBER
FRANKLY YES HIS. SO THERE'S NONE
YEAH I HAVE AS AN AS AMENDED SO
OKAY SO OKAY NEVER MIND. I THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
AMEND WELL AGAIN. GET RID OF
THAT THERE WAS A DISCUSSION OF
AMENDMENT BUT THE AMENDMENTS
THEY WERE WEAK AGREED THE
LANGUAGE IS ALREADY THERE. I DO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS WE HAVE THE
MOTION. UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI DURAZZO. I
THINK ROUTE SO HI HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI WIENER. WIENER HI
FIVE ZERO THE MOTION PASSES FIVE
EIGHT ZERO ALEX THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE WE'RE MOVING ON
EVERY ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA WELCOME SIR. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY MUST BE
THE DAY WE HONOR AND RESPECT OUR
VETERANS AND I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BY THE SENATE
THAT IS THE MEMBERS THAT ARE
HERE AND- AND- THE ENTIRE.
SENATE AND OUR GOVERNOR AND
EVERYONE ELSE I'M SENATOR BOB
ARCHER LET AS YOU KNOW IN ON THE
CHAIR THE MILITARY VETERANS
COMMITTEE AND I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT- THIS BILL BEFORE YOU-
IT PERTAINS TO OUR VETERANS OF
COURSE. AND ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
CHAIR AND HER COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT BILL
PERTAINING TO OUR VETERANS.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
SIX TO MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
AFFORDABLE AND LIVABLE FOR THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED OUR
GREAT NATION AND SACRIFICE SO
VERY MUCH VETERANS LIKE ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING.
ACCORDING TO THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
VETERANS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
MANY VETERANS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. LIVING ON A FIXED INCOME
AND MEDIAN PRICED HOMES OF
COURSE AS YOU ALL KNOW IS
SUCCEEDING IN SOME AREAS. AT
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND WAY OUT
OF THE MARKET FOR SOME OF OUR
VETERANS CALIFORNIA MUST DO MORE
TO ENSURE VETERANS CAN AFFORD TO
LIVE IN OUR GREAT STATE WHILE
STRIVING TO END THE VETERANS
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE- SEE
EVERYWHERE WE GO IT SEEMS LIKE.
THE HARDEST HIT IN THE DREAM OF
HOME PURCHASING AN HONOR
OWNERSHIP SEEMS TO HAVE HIT THE
VETERANS ESPECIALLY ARE 100%
DISABLED VETERANS. ANY BILL
THIRTY FIFTY SO WHIPPER. AN
ADDITIONAL HELPING HAND TO THOSE
HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE A 100%
DISABILITY AND HAVE THAT RATING
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. THIS MEASURE
EXPANDS AND DISABLED VETERANS
EXEMPTION TO ALLOW A FULL
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION. FOR A
100% DISABLED VETERANS. THERE
ARE SEVERAL STATES THAT. THAT
HAVE ALREADY PARTICIPATED THEY
WAY THE PROPERTY TAX 4100%
DISABLED VETERANS INCLUDING
FLORIDA TEXAS. VIRGINIA NEW
MEXICO AND HAWAII TO NAME A FEW.
THIS DISABLED VETERANS EXEMPTION
HONORS THEIR BRAVERY THEIR
COMMITMENT TO OUR COUNTRY WHILE
ALSO ASSISTING OUR DISABLED
VETERANS. WHO ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THE HIGH COST OF LIVING AND
HOMEOWNERSHIP. AS WE LOOK IN THE
FUTURE WE MUST CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN DO AND TRY TO
DO EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY CAN.
TO KEEP OUR VETERANS IN THEIR
HOMES FOR THESE REASONS I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND CALLING
IN TODAY TO TESTIFY AND SUPPORT
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
HAVE ARMY VETERAN AND PURPLE
HEART RECIPIENT MANY MONTANEZ
AND RETIRED MARINE CORPS VETERAN
MICHAEL BARNETT. IF YOU NEED TO
DO THAT ADAM SHARE. THE BILL
BEFORE THEY JUST FIVE. THREE
GOODBYE. VERY GOOD THERE THERE A
MOTION TO PASS THIS BILL SO
WE'LL START WITH THAT MANY
MOUNTAINOUS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME THIS TIME. AS THE
MANAGER SAID MY NAME IS EMMANUEL
MARTINEZ MANNY MONTANEZ I WAS
WAITED THREE MONTHS PRIOR TO MY
TWENTIETH BIRTHDAY IN VIETNAM.
AS A TANK COMMANDER WITH THE
THIRD SQUADRON FOURTH ARMORED
CAMP AT THE TWENTY FIFTH
INFANTRY DIVISION. WHEN MY TANK
WAS HIT BY THREE MOST- ROCKET
PROPELLED GRENADES. I JUST
WANTED TO. PLAY IN BOTH LEGS
BELOW THE WAIST. I DID NOT WALK
FOR OVER A YEAR. HAD IN EXCESS
OF TWENTY ONE SURGERIES TO
REPLACE ARTERIALS OF BONES AT
CETERA AND- VERY LIMITED AT THIS
TIME AT THIS STAGE IN MY CAREER
AT AGE TWENTY FOUR. I- ALSO I AM
A PURPLE HEART RECIPIENT IS THE
SENATOR MANCHIN I LIVE WITH
CONSTANT PAIN BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I LOST A KIDNEY. SIX
YEARS AGO AS THE RESULT OF AGENT
ORANGE FOR THE FOLIAGE THAT WAS
USED. I UP. HAVE BEEN A
HOMEOWNER FOR THIRTY FOUR YEARS
I AM PROUD TO CALL CALIFORNIA MY
HOME. AS MANY VETERANS DO AND I
WANT TO KEEP IT THAT WAY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THANK SENATOR
ARCHULETA A FELLOW VETERAN
AIRBORNE. COOPER FOR CARRYING
THE SLOGAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO THE COUNTRY- WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO MICHAEL BARRETT. SIR YOU
MAY PRESS THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE I'M SORRY NOW
MORNING MEDICARE MAYBE. MY NAME
IS MICHAEL BARRETT- HI SERVED
AND RETIRED FROM THE UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS AFTER TWENTY
ONE YEARS OF ACTIVE MILITARY
SERVICE IN A COMBAT WOUNDED
PURPLE HEART RECIPIENT FROM AN
IED ATTACK IN TWO THOUSAND FOR
THE REST OF MY BODY WAS RAFFLE
SHATTERED MY RIGHT FEMUR SEVERED
MY FEMORAL ARTERY DAMAGE BOTH
YOUR DROWNED. EARNS TO MY FACE
NECK ARMS AND HANDS NOW HAVE A
TITANIUM AND SCREWS GROUP FEVER
MOST NOTHING NERVE DAMAGE THAT
LEFT ME WITH NO MY LOWER RIGHT
LEG I FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
DAYS INCREASE. THROUGH POP TO
HOLD I'D LEARN HOW WALK THE AND
PUSHED MY FOR BE IMITATION GET
BACK IN THE FIGHT YOU SEE AFTER
ALL OF THAT I REENLISTED FOR
FOUR MORE YEARS OF ACTIVE
SERVICE AND DEPLOYED ONCE AGAIN
WITH MY MARINES TO IRAQ. THIS
BILL WILL BRING GREAT RELIEF TO
THE EVER GROWING EXPENSES WE
FACE EACH YEAR AS HOME VALUES
INCREASE SO DO OUR TAXES WHICH
CONTINUE TO PRESENT FINANCIAL
STRESS AND POTENTIAL LOSS OF
INDOOR FOR THE- DOLLAR HOLD. HI
LIKE MANY 1100% DISABLED
VETERANS CONTINUE TO CONSIDER
AND EVEN PLAN TO MOVE OUT OF
CALIFORNIA MORE AFFORDABLE
LOCATION THAT ALREADY HAD A BILL
LIKE THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
INACTION. I TRULY HATE THAT
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY ARE FACED
WITH A DECISION LIKE THIS WE
LOVE CALIFORNIA YOU WANT TO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO REMAIN
POSITIVE PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS AND
WORK VERY HARD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I THINK SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN COMES AT
THE FINAL HOLE FIND IT BETTER IN
THIS FAMILIES CAN AFFORD TO
PURCHASE A HOME THRIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY HOST MILITARY SERVICE.
AND GROW AS A FAMILY IN. THE
WONDERFUL STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BETTER OFF A LOT OF NUMBERS OF
THE STATE SENATE ON BEHALF OF
THAT THEY VETERAN LIKE MIKE. AND
OUR FOR. WE THANK YOU CHRISTINE
GOOD IN ALL OF US. EFFORT TO
FIGHT WAYS TO. ALL BETTER IN OF
. AND SACRIFICED IN DEFENSE OF
THE NATION FREEDOM. I AM. IN THE
PORT OF SB THIRTEEN SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. AND FOR YOU SERVICE
TO OUR COUNTRY. I'M WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO INDIVIDUALS IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS VANESSA CHAVEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU COULD
QUEUE UP THOSE WHO WOULD. LIKE
TO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEDICARE'S TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TO S. R. FOR SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FALL BY ZERO. AS TO FIND
SUPPORT FOR SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. ONE WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE ANYBODY ELSE GOING AT
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. BOB WAS A QUESTION YOU HEARD
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU SIR. OKAY BOB
INSTEAD THE SUPPORT SPENT AROUND
I'M WITH BETTER SHOWING YOU WHAT
SORRY WE'RE CLOSED OFF FOR THE
BILL AND- WE URGE YOU TO PASS SB
13574100% DISABLED VETERANS.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK CENTER%
ARCHULETA- THE CHAIR FOR MEN AND
ALSO BY SHARED MANY MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT PLEASE. WHAT IS LINE SEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. MY NAME IS FRANK
MARCELLO ON A PERMANENT 100%
DISABLED VETERAN US ARMY KRISTER
GAB A RECON POINT MAN- I WAS IN
VIETNAM NINE AND A HALF MONTHS I
GOT BLOWN UP BY A LAND MINE I
HAVE. MALARIA THE WORST I HAD A
GENERAL RANGE I HAVE CANCER MY
SON WAS BORN WITH- WHAT BOTHERS
DRAW AND THAT OF OUR VETERANS
ARE. I GET YOUR- ARE. THIS FOR
LIFE. SO I HAVE BEEN ALL THE
PROBLEMS I'M HAPPY TO BE A
NATIVE. CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE NEXT PLEASE. WE WILL APPLY EIGHTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. IF I PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIRST OF OUR
MY EIGHTY FIVE. YES FIVE HEY
ROBERT BROWER- VIETNAM VETERAN
WITH THE HUNDRED AND FIRST
AIRBORNE DIVISION- A 100% SAID
DISABLED BECAUSE I WORKED IN
THE- NORTHERN PART OF ASIA
VALLEY- THE RECON TEAM AND-
LIVED AND WORKED IN- AGENT
ORANGE WHICH HAS GIVEN ME
PROSTATE CANCER AND- I AM THERE
FOR A 100% DISABLED I RECEIVED
TWO BRONZE STARS WHO WILL PRO
PRO HARD. TO AIR MEDALS- AS A
RESULT OF MY SERVICE CURRENTLY I
A SERVICE OF LEGISLATIVE
COMMISSIONER FOR THE AMERICAN
LEGION AND- OUR LEGISLATIVE
COMMISSIONS- SUPPORTS THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY. NEXT PLEASE. I'M
SURE WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETY ONE
. MY NAME IS TERRY YOU KNOW I'M
A VIETNAM VETERAN. AND ALONG TO
VETERANS STRONG COSPONSORS OF
THIS BILL AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT PLEASE. AND MEDICARE
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP AT THIS
pMOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPETH LEAD OPPOSITION
IDENTIFY SO WE'RE GOING TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THING
NINE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS OR
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FILED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. I'M SURE NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP IT WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- THERE IS A
MOTION ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS SAYING NINE SENATOR
ARCHULETA YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE TO-
TAKE A MOMENT AND PAUSE AND
THANK ALL THE VETERANS WHO'VE
CALLED IN- THOSE WHO ARE AT A
100% AND THOSE WHO SUPPORT OUR
VETERANS WHO ARE AT A HUNDRED
PERCENT. AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS- AND FOR THE NUMBER
OF MEMBERS THEY HAVE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
HAVE- A FEW VETERANS SPRINKLED
OUT NEAR ASSOCIATION BUT BELIEVE
IN HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR EVERYONE
EQUALLY AND FAIRLY AND THIS
GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
VETERANS TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT.
AND I'D CERTAINLY LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE- AS
IDEA. I TRIED TO THINK ABOUT MY
SERVICE BUT I DON'T NEED TO DO
THAT I JUST NEED TO SAY THANK
YOU AND URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD THEIR
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS CAPITO HI
CABALLERO HI NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN HI DURAZO. TERRAZZO HI
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG HI
WIENER. WIENER HI FIVE ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO ZERO AND
CENTER GILLETTE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICES WELL WE DON'T
SAY IT ENOUGH. VERY GOOD WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
DOT SIX ON THE AGENDA IT IS A
BILL BY SENATOR WELCOME- SENATOR
NELSON IF I MADE A MADAM CHAIR I
WOULD REQUEST PERMISSION TO
PRESENT THIS FOR CENTER WILK AT
HIS REQUEST ABSOLUTELY SENATOR
AND IF I'M ABLE JUST PRESENT
FROM RIGHT HERE CAN PRESENT FROM
THE FROM THE DICE IF YOU LIKE
THIS IS A CENTER WORKS BILL IS
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE AS-
PRESENTED BY SENATOR NIELSEN MAY
PROCEED WITH THIS MEASURE IS I
THINK KIND OF CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA DEALING. WITH THE
HOMELESS. PROBABLES TRAVAIL IN
CRISIS IT REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
REPORTING BY THE STATE AND
LOCALITIES ON HOMELESS PROGRAM
EXPENDITURES AND OUTCOMES. I
WOULD ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH SENATOR WILK
AND HIS STAFF ON THESE MEASURES
SO WE WILL ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AS AMENDED THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
REPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL. SPECIFIED
INFORMATION ON THIS HOMELESS
POPULATION AS WELL AS THE
EXPENDITURES ON HOMELESS
PROGRAMS FOR THEIR JURISDICTIONS
BUT JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THE COUNCIL WILL BE
CHARGED TO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION CONDUCT AN
ASSESSMENT AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IMPOSED ON LINE BUT
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. THERE'S BEEN PROGRESS FOR
SURE OVER THE YEARS WITH OUR
HOMELESS. POPULATION. BUT I TEND
TO CHARACTERIZE AND I'VE HAD A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
ISSUE AS ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
ENSURE HAVE. BUT I CHARACTERIZE
HOW THIS HAS DEALT WITH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. AS
EXEMPLIFIED BY THE- ABSTRACT
ARTIST. WHO COMES INTO A WHITE
PAINTED ROOM WITH THE BUCKET.
LET'S JUST START WITH THE BRUSH
SPLASHING. THE PAINT ON THE WALL. NOW I AM VERY INVOLVED IN THE
ART COMMUNITY AND ALWAYS HAVE
THE- THEN THAT IS IN THE DARK.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE STATE. WHAT
THAT REPRESENTS IS ALL WE'RE
DOING IS THROWING MONEY AT THAT
THANKS. THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO
BRING SOME ACCOUNTABILITY AND
FOCUS ON NOT JUST. THROWING
MONEY AT IT BUT ENSURING. THAT
THERE ARE RESULTS FOR THE MONEY
EXPENDED. SURELY THIS PARTICULAR
PROBLEM IS NOT APPLICABLE JUST
TO THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND
POPULATION. THAT APPLIES TO MOST
EVERYTHING WE DO AND GOVERNMENT
. BUT THIS IS A LEGITIMATE
ATTEMPT TO BRING SOME SETS.
SENSE AND PURPOSE TO DEALING
WITH THE HOMELESS. THERE'S BEEN
A RECENTLY LAUNCHED HOMELESS
DATA INTEGRATION SYSTEM. THE
WEBSITE IN PLACE NOW IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT
INFORMATION IS STILL LACKING. AS
IF POPULATION INFORMATION AS
PRESENTED IS LIMITED. THE BILL
AS A STEP FURTHER INTO THE
DIRECTION WHICH OTHER STATES
HAVE ALREADY TAKEN INCLUDING
WASHINGTON WHICH TRACKS ALL
FUNDING AND EXPENDITURE FOR
EVERY HOMELESS PROJECT. IN THE
STATE FROM EVERY FUNDING SOURCE
TO IDENTIFY SUCCESSFUL PROJECTS
ON WHICH IT COULD EXPAND AND
FOCUS ON GREATER EFFORT. EXPEND
FINANCIAL RESOURCES FOR SUCH
PURPOSES. THIS BILL WAS INSPIRED
BY THE FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS OF TWO STATE
AUDITS LAST YEAR. ONE WAS IN
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. ONE WAS IN
TWENTY TWENTY. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO GET A HANDLE ON WHAT WE'RE
DOING. IT HAS DISTURBED ME AS
I'VE WATCHED COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT. STRUGGLE WITH
HOMELESSNESS. BUT IT'S ALSO BEEN
CLEARLY EVIDENT THAT THERE'S NOT
BEEN MUCH WITH THIS ISSUE. OF
COORDINATION. AND BENEFITING
FROM POSITIVE EXPERIENCES OF ANY
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY. AND THIS
IS A BILL I THINK THAT BRINGS
ACCOUNTABILITY BY PROVIDING
INFORMATION THAN MEASURES. THE
SUCCESS OR FAILURE. MADAM CHAIR
IF I MAY I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY. WE HAVE
CHRIS. PATELLA INVENTS CABLE NOW
THESE ARE SENIOR AUDITORS IN THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE THEY ARE
PRESENTING HERE JUST FOR
INFORMATION'S SAKE THEN MAYBE IN
RESPONSE TO QUESTIONS THEY ARE
NOT FORMALLY TAKING ANY POSITION
. THE AGENCY DOES NOT DO THAT
BUT WE DO HAVE THEM AVAILABLE.
OF THOSE GENTLEMAN HERE. THERE
WE GO THANK YOU SIR PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE CHAIR
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS VANCE CABLE AND I'M A SENIOR
AUDITOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE. AS
SENATOR NIELSEN INDICATED THE
STATE AUDITOR DOES NOT TAKE A
POSITION AGAINST OR FOR PROPOSED
LEGISLATION HOWEVER THAT BEING
SAID SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE WHAT ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT
WE IDENTIFIED IN AN AUDIT REPORT
THAT WE ISSUED OUT HOMELESSNESS-
IN FEBRUARY OF LAST YEAR. THOSE
CONCERNS SPECIFICALLY WERE THAT
THE STATE DID NOT HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW IT SPEND STATE FUNDS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. AND AT THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO COLLECT
COMPREHENSIVE DATA AS PART OF
THE HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM. MAY BE LIMITED BECAUSE
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO RECEIVE
STATE FUNDING ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO ENTER INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
PROGRAMS. MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS
PATEL IS AVAILABLE I CAN ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT AUDIT.
DURING THE SUBSEQUENT AUDIT WE
RAISE THE SPECIFIC CONCERNS THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT HAD NOT HISTORICALLY
COLLECTED ANALYZED OR REPORTED
DATA. USING OUTCOME MEASURES FOR
ANY OF ITS HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS
. WHILE EIGHT CD DOES PROVIDE A
NUMBER OF OUTPUTS RELATED TO
FIGHTING HOMELESSNESS SUCH AS
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AWARDED AND THE NUMBER OF
APARTMENTS OR HOMES THAT WERE
FUNDED- THAT WERE PRESERVED
CREATED AND REHABILITATED. HCD
DOES NOT REPORT OUTCOME MEASURES
THAT DESCRIBED WHETHER ITS
ACTIONS WERE AFFECTED OF A
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS OR
AT RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
MEASURING OUTCOMES IS CRITICAL
NOT ONLY FOR UNDERSTANDING HOW
WELL THE STATE USES ITS FUNDING.
BUT ALSO TO INFORM FUTURE
EFFORTS TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA COULD
BENEFIT FROM COLLECTING
ANALYZING AND REPORTING OUTCOME
INFORMATION AS WE FOUND THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON HAS DONE.
MISTER PATEL AND I ARE AVAILABLE
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD
HI MISTER PATEL DID YOU WISH TO
SPEAKER JUST ANSWER QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD HELLO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ON THIS WE ARE- REQUESTING THAT
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. SEEING NINE WILL MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IS-
IT MISTER MODERATOR IS OR ANYONE
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE. MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE LINE. YEAH I AM SO SORRY
MADAM CHAIR I WAS TALKING TO
MYSELF MUTED IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FIVE EIGHT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT TO SB THIRTY FIFTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
I'M SURE NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
VERY GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION. USE ME WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IDENTIFIED SO WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THING NINE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE. TESTIFYING
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO. AND
HERE NOBODY'S QUEUING UP IT WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. SENATOR
EYES SO. JUST QUESTION WHETHER
IT IS TO CENTER NIELSEN OR THE
AUDITOR IS. DID YOU I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T READ THE- THE REPORT OF
THE AUDITORS REPORT BUT IS ANY
OF THIS- INFORMATION BEING
COLLECTED AT. ANY LEVEL WHAT
WHAT DID YOU FIND AS FAR AS- THE
INFORMATION THAT. IS OUT THERE
ARE WE STARTING FROM SCRATCH OR
ARE WE ADDING TO SOMETHING
THAT'S ALREADY THERE. YES HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CHRIS
PATEL FOR THE RECORD I'M WITH A
COMPANY STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE I
WAS THE SUPERVISOR THAT OVERSAW
THE AUDIT OF THE- CONTINUANCE OF
CARE WHICH WE ISSUED LAST YEAR
IN FEBRUARY- SO THIS DATA IS
BEING COLLECTED- FOR THE C. O.
C. PROGRAM TO CONTINUE OF CARE
PROGRAM WHICH IS A FEDERAL
PROGRAM- IT IS ADMINISTERED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THE MONEY GOES
STRAIGHT TO THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS- WITHIN THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE- THEY ARE BY LAW
REQUIRED- TO- SUBMIT CERTAIN
DATA WITHIN THE- THE SYSTEM THAT
THEY USE WHICH IS CALLED THE
HOMELESS MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM. HOWEVER MANY OF THE
OTHER STATE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
OF MONEY THAT IS- PROVIDED
THROUGH THE STATE PROGRAMS- THEY
MAY NOT BE ACQUIRING- THAT THE
COLLECTS OF. ANY ANY OF THE
STATE. SO THERE'S- INFORMATION
THAT. IS THAT IS THAT THE YOU
SAID THE FEDERAL PROGRAM-
ADMINISTERED THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT INFORMATION THAT GOES TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
COME TO THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS CORRECT CURRENTLY THERE
IS NO MECHANISM AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO COLLECT ALL THE
INFORMATION- AT THE AGGREGATE
LEVEL- THAT WAS THE INTENTION OF
THE- THE H. D. I. A SYSTEM THAT
THE STATE WAS PLANNING TO
IMPLEMENT. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SENIOR FOR THE
QUESTIONS I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. OUR MOTION FOLKS. NOW
MOVES CENTER NIELSEN MAKES THE
MOTION THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN BY TORONTO I
GREW ALSO HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HI WIENER RIGHT WIENER HI. FIVE
ZERO MOTION PASSES FIVE TWO
ZERO. YEAH I ON BEHALF OF CENTER
AYE THANK MY COLLEAGUES AND I
THINK MISTER PATEL AND MR CABLE
FOR THEIR- TESTIMONY THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. REMOVE THE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS SB FOURTEEN OH FIVE BY
SENATOR OCHO A VOTE. WELCOME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WHAT. PERFECT HEIGHT. I DO AGREE
WITH. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT ANTHONY FOR THEIR
HARD WORK IN THIS BILL. I AM
HAPPY TO ACCEPT ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THE
COMMUNITY OF LIKE YOUR HEAD IS A
UNIQUE MOUNTAIN COMMUNITY
LOCATED IN SAN MARINO MOUNTAINS
THAT IS FAIRLY ISOLATED AT FIVE
THOUSAND FEET IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREA OF SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY. CURRENTLY THE
COMPANY CONDITIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS REFERRED TO AS CCN
OURS IN ERROR HEAD WOULD ARE
ENFORCED BY THE ERRO HEAD WITH
ARCHITECTURAL COMMITTEE KNOWN
AS- IRAQ. WHICH IS WHAT WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED BY A GROUP OF
CONCERNED AT LAKE ARROWHEAD
RESIDENTS IN NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE TO PRESERVE THE UNIQUE
GLORIOUS SCENERY OF LAKE
ARROWHEAD. BECAUSE OF A LACK WAS
FORMED BEFORE THE DAVIS STERLING
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENT ACT
IT WAS NOT BORN AS AN H. AWAY
AND THEREFORE DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO CHARGE FEES TO
COVER THE COST OF THEIR
OPERATIONS. THE ONLY REVENUE THE
ORGANIZATION RECEIVED IS FROM
THE APPLICATION FEES AND PENALTY
FEE. PENALTY FEES. UP FOR LACK
OF COMPLIANCE WHICH ARE OFTEN
DIFFICULT FOR A WORK WHICH IS A
NONPROFIT TO COLLECT. WITH TEN
THOUSAND PARCELS ENFORCEMENT IS
A MAJOR CHALLENGE FOR A WHACK.
ONLY IN IRAQ ONLY HAS ONE FULL
TIME AND ONE PART TIME STAFF
PERSON. AS A RESULT REVENUE
GENERATION IS UNCERTAIN ANY
GIVEN YEAR AND COST INCREASES
AND LEGAL CHALLENGES MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO ANTICIPATE COST.
FOR THESE REASONS THEY ARE FACED
WITH A FINANCIAL CRISIS. THAT IS
WHY THEY HAVE REQUESTED THAT THE
LAKE ARROWHEAD COMMUNITY SERVICE
DISTRICT KNOWN AS LA CST. TAKE
OVER THE ENFORCEMENT OF THE CCN
OURS IN ARROWHEAD WOODS. L. A.
CST IS ONE OF THE FEW LOCALLY
ELECTED AGENCIES IN THE AREA
THEY CURRENTLY PROVIDE WATER
SERVICES TO THE PROPERTIES IN
ERRO HEAD BOARDS AND THEIR STAFF
ARE ALREADY IN THE FIELD
VISITING PROPERTIES ON A DAILY
BASIS. THIS PUTS THEM IN A
UNIQUE POSITION TO MONITOR AND
ENFORCE COMPLIANCE IN A MUCH
MORE COMPREHENSIVE AND EFFICIENT
MANNER. TO ACCOMPLISH THIS L. A.
CST NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED
AUTHORIZATION TO ADD THE
ENFORCEMENT OF CCN OURS TO ITS
POWERS. GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION
SIXTY ONE ONE ZERO FIVE
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THEIR UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT EXIST IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES THAT
JUSTIFIED THE ENACTMENT OF
SPECIAL FIX STATUTES FOR
SPECIFIC DISTRICTS. AND WE
BELIEVE THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
EXIST IN THIS CASE. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE LAKE
ARROWHEAD COMMUNITY S. B.
FOURTEEN ZERO FIVE ADDS THE LAKE
ARROWHEAD COMMUNITY SERVICE
DISTRICT TO THE LIST OF
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS IN
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION. SIX ONE
ONE ZERO FIVE. BETTER AUTHORIZED
TO ENFORCE CCN OURS. JOINING ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
CATHERINE SERI. ON BEHALF OF
LAKE ARROWHEAD COMMUNITY
SERVICES DISTRICT AND CC LYFORD
ON BEHALF OF THE ERROR HEAD
WOODS ARCHITECTURAL COMMITTEE
ALSO JOINING ON THE LINE WILL BE
JOE BURN WITH L. A. CST TO WHO
IS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. VERY GOOD I
HAVE- JOSEPH BYRNE- AND
CATHERINE SERI AS THE TWO
WITNESSES I THINK YOU MENTIONED
SOMEONE ELSE CATHERINE YES WE
HAD- WHAT C. YES CATHERINE AND
STACY LEIPER. OKAY SO- WHO WILL
BE THE ONE THAT- IT CAN ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND THEN. OKAY SO JUST
OF BURNABY WILL BE HELD IN IT IN
RESERVE. READ THERE YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO WITNESSES SO I'M
ASSUMING IS A C. LIBRARY YES
CATHERINE'S JERRY OKAY VERY
GOOD- WE WILL- ASK STACY LEIBER
IF- IF YOU'D LIKE TO GIVE
TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
STACEY LIPPERT I'M WITH THE
ARROWHEAD WITH ARCHITECTURAL
COMMITTEE. ZERO WITH
ARCHITECTURAL COMMITTEE IS
SEEKING A PARTNER TO ENSURE
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE CCN OURS.
FOR A HUNDRED YEARS THERE'S BEEN
SOME SORT OF ARCHITECTURAL
COMMITTEE TASKED WITH ENFORCING
THE FIFTEEN HOURS TO PRESERVE
THE CHARACTER OF THE YEAR OKAY
WITH. HE LACKED THE SAKE THE
RESOURCES TO SUCCESSFULLY
PROTECT AND ENFORCE THE CCN OURS
. WE HAVE ONE FULL TIME AND ONE
PART TIME EMPLOYEE. L. A. FIFTY
ON THE OTHER HAND ALREADY SERVED
WATER TO VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE
PROPERTIES AND THE TRACK. HAVE
STAFF THAT ARE OUT IN THE FIELD
EVERY DAY AND INTERACT PROPERTY
OWNERS THREE SOUTHEAST AREA ON A
DAILY BASIS. THE DOCKING AND
COMMUNICATION ABILITY WOULD
ENABLE IRAQ TO BETTER EDUCATE
ALL PROPERTY OWNERS WITHIN ERRO
HEADLIGHTS. AND BETTER ENFORCE
THE CCN OURS. THAT'S THE FOUND
IN MEXICO OVER 20% OF PROPERTIES
IN ERRO HEAD FLICK HAS
TRANSFERRED OWNERSHIP THE NEW
PROPERTY OWNERS ARE MODIFIED OF
PROPERTIES WHICH REQUIRE
COMMITTEE ON A VERY LARGE SCALE.
IRAQ IS FINDING IT INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT TO KEEP UP WITH THE
MAN.EDUCATION AND ENFORCEMENT
UTILITY AND FLOOD OF NEW OWNERS
. IF THE VISION A WHERE TO MAKE
CERTAIN. OF STANDARDS
CONSTRUCTION IN BE ERROL HAD
WITH AREA ARCHITECTURAL DESIGNS
THAT ARE HARMONIOUS TO THE
SURROUNDING HOMES AND
LANDSCAPES. IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS THAT WE ARE SEEKING A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE L. A. CST
AND HOPE YOU WILL SEE THAT AND
AFFIRMATIONS BOAT IS BENEFICIAL
TO THE AVAILABILITY OF. THE VCRS
AND PRESERVING- OF THE- HECKLER
. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CATHERINE SERI. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND NOT VERY DIGITAL
MANAGER OF THE LAKE ARROWHEAD
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL ALONG WITH
A LACK. WITH THEIR UNIQUE AND
BEAUTIFUL WORLD AREA AND THE
STAMINA DINO MOUNTAINS THE PSP
IS THE PRIMARY GOVERNMENT
AGENCY. ELECTED BECAUSE THAT'S
WE PROTECT THE FORESTS AND
MAINTAIN THE CHARACTER OF LAKE
ARROWHEAD PRESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGH THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE EXISTING
RECORDED FIJIAN OURS. IT WORKED
OUT FOR AGENCY TO PARTNER WITH
THEM AND WE ARE FULLY SUPPORTIVE
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS ARE AWFUL
TIME RESIDENTS IN BELIEVING IN
OUR THIRD PARTY MAINTAINED. IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND SPEAKING
MAGICALLY ECKSTINE TREMENDOUS
TURNOVER IN THE REAL ESTATE
MARKET A THREE MODEL ACTIVITIES
HAVE INCREASED ADDING KATIE'S
OTHER STATES. HAS BECOME CLEAR-THAT WE NEED A MORE STREAMLINED
PROCESS. BECAUSE WE ARE
INCORPORATED. FREE TEXT BUILDING
PERMIT APPROVED THROUGH THE
COUNTY WHICH DOESN'T HAVE
ORDINANCES ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE ERROR HIS WAYS. IN OURS.
THEY ARE OFTEN ON A FORM ABOUT
THE- BUT THEY CAN THEY CAN BE
REQUIRED YES DO YOU SIGN OFF
BEFORE FOR. ARE FREE. WORKING
WE'LL BE TO ENSURE. EFFICIENT
COMMITTEE FIVE AND SECRETARY THE
FOR AND- SEATER CLICK HERE
HEALTH. THE ONE I THINK SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR A- NO FOR A AND
FROM STAFF. THE AUTHOR OF YOU
THINK CAN. AS WELL AS A HIGH.
POTENTIAL INTO THE ITEM YOU FOR
THE FOR MATTER YOU TO. WE ARE
WANT TO THANK CALIFORNIA SISTER
TO THIRTY FOR SUPPORT IN
ADDITION. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
CONSIDER. AND WE WERE JUST.
REQUEST AND I. VERY GOOD RECEIVE
THERE'S ANYONE WHO IN THE
COMMITTEE THAT LIKE TO IN
SUPPORT. THANK WILL GO TO THE
TWO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
MISTER IF YOU COULD- AND INVITED
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THEM. THANK
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY- FOR SB ONE FOUR OH FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TWO FIVE ONE FOUR OR FIVE
TO TEST BY SUPPORT. AND ONE
MOMENT MADAM CHAIR. WE DO HAVE
ONE QUEUING UP WITH AN OPERATION
WE WITH THIS MOMENTARILY ANYBODY
ELSE PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN PRESS ONE ZERO
TWO TWO- SB FOURTEEN OH FIVE.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MARKETS THAT WHILE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
pQUEUED UP MEDICARE VERY GOOD
WILL MOVE ON TO THE OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO LEAD OPPOSITION
IDENTIFIED SO WHEN A CHECK TO
SEE IF ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. DESPITE OPPOSITION
FOR SB FORK IN OFFICE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE FOUR
ZERO FIVE AT THIS TIME. AND I'M
SURE NOBODY IS GOING UP VERY
GOOD WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUESTION FOR
JOE BYRNE WHO'S THE TECHNICIAN
ON THIS LINE WAS ONLINE THE
FORMER PER CHAIR OF THE-
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION I
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
RELATIONSHIP IS BETWEEN THIS
DISTRICT. AND A LA THE- AT LAKES
ASSOCIATION IF YOU CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND THAT TERMS OF THE
REVENUE STREAM. SURE THANK YOU
AND- GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY IN
CENTER HERTZBERG USE MY FORMER
BOSS WHEN I WORKED IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. HE SAID. TRANSACTION
THE. ZERO IT LIKE IT DOES IS
THAT IT IS ENTITY THAT MANAGES
THE LAKE ITSELF- AND ACCESS TO
THE LAKE AND A VERY SMALL STRIP
OF LAND AROUND THE LAKE- THEY IN
FACT- YOU HAVEN'T QUIT CLAIMED
IT WOULD BE HAD SOME INTEREST IN
OUR YEARS AGO AND THEY HAVE
TRANSFERRED THOSE TO A WHACK SO
THERE'S NO RELATIONSHIP IN ANY
L. A. IS ALSO NOT A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION EITHER IT'S ALSO A
NONPROFIT WHO THE OWNER OF THE
PROPERTY WHICH THE LAKE IS ON IN
THIS TRIP OF A PROPERTY AROUND
THE LAKE. YEAH BUT IS IT TRUE
THAT THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
CONTROL ALL THE POWER BECAUSE IF
YOU CONTROL THE LAKE YOU CONTROL
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT WITH THAT NO
FURTHER COMMENT MISTER BURNING
YOU'VE ALWAYS DO A GOOD JOB. I
HAVE MOVED A BILL. THERE IS A
MOST ANY OTHER. OR ARE. THING
THEN. YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM. I'M SURE.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THIS
TRANSITION CAN OCCUR IN THAT THE
CCN OURS PUT IN PLACE FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF ERROR HAD WHICH-
CAN CONTINUE TO BE ENFORCED
EFFICIENTLY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. PLEASE KALRA SENATORS
CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI DURAZO. TERRAZZO HI
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG HI
WIENER. WIENER HI. FIVE ZERO.
THE BILL THAT PASSES FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
ON THE AGENDA SENATOR STERN YOU
ARE UP AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THIS IS SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE. OKAY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I THOUGHT I MIGHT
GET LUCKY AND- SLIP THE CUTE
HERE BUT- FREESHEET YOUR TIME
AND I REALLY WANT TO FIRST START
OFF BY NOT JUST ACCEPTING THE
MEMBERS LIST IN THE ANALYSIS ON
PAGES TO THOSE ARE COMMENTS TWO
AND THREE BUT- THANK YOUR STAFF
FOR MAKING THIS MUCH BETTER
BILL- THEY ROUNDED IT OUT- PUTS
IN KEY DETAILS IN THERE. WE PUT
A FINER POINT ON WHAT I THINK IS
THE ESSENCE OF THIS BILL IS THAT
EVERY PERSON REGARDLESS WHERE
YOU LIVE IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD
HAVE OPPORTUNITY ACCESS OPEN
SPACE IT CHANGES FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE. WEALTHIER YOU KNOW LIVE ON
A HILLSIDE OR MOUNTAIN SIDE- AND
WE'RE HOPING HERE IS THAT THIS
BILL STIMULATE A CONVERSATION
WITH LEADERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ALL AROUND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO LOOK AT UPDATES
THEIR OPEN SPACE ELEMENTS WE
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF EFFORT
BEING PUT INTO OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THE GENERAL PLAN BUT- WE THINK
HIS EMPHASIS ON THE OPEN SPACE
ELEMENT. AND TAKING EQUITY INTO
ACCOUNT- TAKING RESILIENCE
INSERT OPPORTUNITIES TO GO
BEYOND JUST OUR TRADITIONAL
MOTIVE GOING THROUGH
CONSERVANCIES ARE GOING THROUGH
SORT OF- AGENCIES THAT ALREADY
HAVE OPPORTUNITY SET UP TO MAKE
THOSE ACQUISITIONS IF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE GETTING HEADED
IS. IDENTIFYING OPPORTUNITIES
IDENTIFYING LANDS- AND REALLY
PUTTING EQUITY FIRST I THINK WE
CAN MAKE SOME SERIOUS PROGRESS-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES HEALTHIER
AND HAPPIER- WE CAN TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE DETAILS OF
YOUR ONE AND THERE'S A THERE'S
MANY CITIES THAT HAVEN'T UPDATED
THEIR- OPEN SPACE ELEMENTS FOR
MANY DECADES- THIS IS TRUE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
CENTRAL NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- BUT
WE REALLY WANT THIS TO BE A
CLATTER PROCESS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT- IF THE BILL SHOULD MOVE
FOR WE CAN KEEP. WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN AND TRY TOSEEK SOME RESOLUTION THE LAST
THEY WERE JUST NOTE THE
IMPORTANT OTHER CHANGE MADE IS
THE COUPLING THIS FROM THE
HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATE AND
SETTING A DATE OF TWENTY TWENTY
SIX I THINK WILL PROVIDE A LOT
OF CLARITY BECAUSE THERE'S A
LITTLE CONFUSION AS TO HOW
LINKING THOSE WOULD ACTUALLY
WORK SO THIS IS NOW DECOUPLED
FROM THE HOUSING PROCESS AND YOU
JUST- ON HIS OWN FOR STANDALONE.
SO WITHOUT IT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE HAPPY TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS I'VE GOT. AND TO FOLKS
TESTIFYING TODAY. ONE OF THE-
LOCAL INTEREST REPRESENTATIVE
WHO'S BEEN WORKING OPEN SPACE
ISSUES IN THE LA AREA AND THEN-
THAT'S JAMIE HALL AND DANCE EVER
WITH THE ENDANGERED HABITATS
LEAGUE. VERY GOOD. MISTER HALL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
JAMIE HALL ARE I AM HERE TODAY
CAN BE ACTIVELY SUPPORT THE
STILL ON THE PRESIDENT OF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT THE
LAUREL CANYON LAND TRUST OUR
MISSION IS SIMPLE TO PRESERVE
OPEN SPACE AND NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT LAUREL CANYON IS
TOPS MEDIAN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS LOCATED IN THE HEART
OF LOS ANGELES. WE WERE FORMED
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHERE
PRINCIPAL ORGANIZER KIND ELECT
MOUNTAIN PROJECT THE SEATTLE
EFFORT DEVICE THE MAKING
MOUNTAIN LITTLE CAN HOME TO WHAT
ONE OF WALKING AND OAK DEAR BOB
. AND THEN CALLER NOW LINE WITH
WAS RECENTLY DECLARED THREATENS
. WHAT THE HELP OF HUNDRED DISS
THE SENATE MONICA NOT CONSERVE
PER FAMILY DOWN. EVEN DON HENLEY
OF EAGLES WE WERE ABLE TO RAISE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
PERMANENTLY PRESERVE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE PARCEL
WHICH IS LOCATED LESS THAN ONE
MILE FROM HOLLYWOOD BOULEVARD
SINCE THEN WE'VE WORKED A CHOIR
OVER. TEN ACRES OF ADDITIONAL
LAND. IT IS THE BILL THE CITY I
LIVE IN. THE CITY OF LOS. AT AN
OPEN SPACE. THAT IS FOR NINE YOU
OLD. CONTACT IT WAS. WHEN WE NAY
LAFAYETTE. IN CITY OF LA MODELO
IN HAVE A SORE OUT OF DATE PLAN
ACCORDING TO DATA BY OFFICE
PLANNING AND- ORGANS HAS STEP UP
TO THE PLATE HELLO MEANS IN OPEN
PRESERVATION APPLE OF LOCAL
STATE. BETTER DESIGN TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY THIS BILL WILL CORRECT
THAT. OUR LEGISLATION FOR MANY
MANY YEARS AGO THAT OPEN SPACE
TO THE MATH IS MATH. TO MAINTAIN-THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND ENSURE
THE CONTINUED AVAILABILITY OF
LAND FOR THE PRODUCTION OF FOOD
AND FIBER. ENJOYMENT OF SCENIC
BEAUTY FOR RECREATION OR FOR THE
USE OF NATURAL RESOURCES. IN
FACT THE VALUE IN BENEFIT OF
OPEN SPACE WITH HIGHLIGHTED.
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WERE FIRST
FORCED TO QUARANTINE DURING THE
RECENT PANDEMIC. ACTIVE THE OPEN
SPACE PROVIDED ESSENTIAL RELIEF
FROM THE URBAN ENVIRONMENT
DURING THIS TIME. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN THE STATE HAVE AN UP
TO DATE MASTER PLAN FOR THE
PRESERVATION. OF OPEN SPACE IN
THEIR JURISDICTIONS. THIS IS ALL
THE MORE. CONSIDERING THE
AMBITION GOAL STATE HAS
COMMITTED TO IT PART OF THE
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY MICHIGAN. AND
THIRTY FIRST WORLD. LANDON WHY
YOUR TWENTY. ALL WAY THAT WE ARE
TO NEED THIS CAR IS TO. PLANNING
THANK. OUR CRITICAL THIS BILL
ALL WE PARDON ACTION. DEVELOP
IMPLEMENT THIS OPEN SPACE. CAN
ALL AGREE IT MAKES NO THE NOW
PLAN. THERE THEN CONSCIOUS THE
COURT THE- WE'RE DOING BIG AND
BOLD THINGS AND PRESERVATION OF
SPACE CERTAIN ONE OF THEM. BUT
IT ALSO WITH THE- THIS IS WHY
THIS BILL. AND I HAVING ENTERED
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE THANKS
VERY MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO NOW
COME. OVER GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM DANCE
WITH A DIFFERENT HAPPENED WITH
THE AND WE ARE PLEASE TO AND S.
B. FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE COULD
RANDY OUT OF THE GATE OPEN SPACE
ELEMENTS AND TO ADDRESS PRESSING
ISSUES OF OUR TIMES IN REGARD TO
OPEN SPACE. FOR YOUR REFERENCE
DANGER HABITATS LEAGUE IS A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
CONSERVATION GROUP DEDICATED TO
ECOSYSTEM PROTECTION AND
SUSTAINABLE LAND USE WITH
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE WITH OPEN
SPACE ELEMENTS AS WE'VE BEEN
STAKEHOLDERS IN GENERAL PLAN AND
OPEN SPACE ELEMENT UPDATES IN
SAN DIEGO RIVERSIDE. AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTIES. OUR NATURAL SO
FROM OF HOW AND CLIMATE. AND
OTHER GROW- POP. NEED OUR TO
NATURE FOR HEALTH AND WELL. OPEN
SPACE ELEMENTS ARE INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT. SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE WOULD ENSURE THAT THE OPEN
SPACE ON THIS UPDATED THAT WOULD
ENSURE THAT THE DRESSES KEY
CONTEMPORARY ISSUES. THESE
INCLUDE EQUITY AND ACCESS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
SUCH A STRONG CONNECTIVITY. AND
LAUGH PROTECTION. AS WELL AS
OFFER. TO DEGRADED AREAS FOR
DEPLETED SPECIES. ENDANGERED
HABITATS LEAGUE ENDORSES SP
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE AS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO MAINTAIN THE
QUALITY. OF BOTH NATURAL AND
HUMAN COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MINISTRY OF
ANYONE IN ROOM. TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. SEEING NONE.
MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE IF YOU COULD PROMPT.
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT BY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FALL BY ZERO. AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE NINETY SIX YOU ARE OPEN
. HI THIS IS SANTIAGO WITH
CALIFORNIA'S FARMING COMPETITORS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. EXCELLENT ON ONE OF
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS KIM DELFINO- BOBBY HAPPY TO
FIVE DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
BOTTOM LINE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AND THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT OF THAT FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. I DON'T KNOW
EITHER PARTISAN QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME MEDICARE. VERY GOOD
THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION THERE THERE ARE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES. WILL
START HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEAMAN WILL MOVE ON
TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE AND
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCING THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU THE MANAGER SAID TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY
ZERO. MEDICARE NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP. VERY GOOD WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
SENATOR HURT HERTZBERG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR YOU HAVE ANOTHER STAFFER
THAT. I'M JUST GETTING YOU
STATES THAT HER STAFF. THE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR DOING THIS I
THINK IT'S A GREAT BILL I'M
GONNA MOVE IT AND I ALSO WANNA.
IN ADDITION TO THE COMMENT THAT
WAS MADE ABOUT DON HENLEY TO
GIVE A LITTLE MORE CONTEXT ON
THE HISTORY BECAUSE OF A NUMBER
OF OTHER FOLKS THAT OFTEN DON'T
GET CREDIT. IN TERMS OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS WITH
RESPECT OPEN SPACE- IN ADDITION
TO DON HENLEY WARREN BEATTY
DONATED MATH MUCH OF THE LAND
FOR FRYMAN CANYON JACK NICHOLSON
WAS VERY INVOLVED GAIL HEARD OF
THAT THE PRODUCERS TO BE MARRIED
TO JAMES JAMES CAMERON ALL HOST
OF FOLKS THAT- MARK FABIANI WITH
TOM BRADLEY'S OFFICE WHO IS THE
CHIEF OF STAFF TO WORK ON ALL
THIS STUFF AND- REALLY IMPORTANT
STUFF THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
EFFORTS OF FOOT. AND IT'S A BIG
DEAL I'D OVE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR TO MOVE THE BILL AND
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS IT'S
IMPORTANT REALLY BORED. FORGET
THERE IS A MOTION ANY MORE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS SAYING
NINE. SENATOR STERN YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. AT BEFORE. I'LL JUST
SAY- THOSE ACTIONS SANTA MONICA
MANNS HAVE BEEN CRUCIAL. BUT IF
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT THE SIDE OF
LA LOOKS LIKE. THE FACT THAT
THERE I THINK IT. AVERAGED TWO
ACRES OPEN SPACE FOR EVERY
THOUSAND RESIDENTS OF A OF A
TOWN LIKE EL SERENO. RELEVANT
HILLS SITTING THERE. IN THAT
FRANKLY IS USE A DUMPING GROUND
AND SHOULD BE RESTORED AND
PRESERVED. THOSE ARE THE
FORGOTTEN PLACES THAT WERE
LOOKING TO RESTORE WITH THIS.
AND PUT EQUITY FIRST WHEN IT
COMES TO OPEN SPACE SO. THANK
YOU FOR THE SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DO
APPRECIATE- YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. BUT FIRST DEMAND AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS CAPITO HI
CABALLERO HI. NIELSEN NIELSEN HI
DURAZO HI DURAZO HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI WIENER. WIENER HI.
FIVE ZERO MOTION PASSES FIVE TWO
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH REMOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
WHICH IS SENATOR HERTZBERG IT IS
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO.
WHAT'S GOING ON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS AND MADAM CHAIR.
LET ME BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE
TAKING THE TIME THANKS TO CHAIR
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE SO MANY YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN IN IN IN THE- GOVERNMENT
WHERE WE GET OUT THERE AND WE
PASS A LAW AND WE TRY TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM AND THERE'S ALWAYS
SOME LEVEL OF CHALLENGE ALONG
THE WAY IN TERMS OF HOW IT GETS
IMPLEMENTED. AND WHETHER OR NOT
OUR INTENT WAS. OTHERWISE
INCLUDED EVERY I'M LOOKING IN
YOUR REMEMBER YOUR HUSBAND CAME
TO ME ON A BILL WE HAD TO MAKE A
NUMBER OF CHANGES WAY BACK WHEN
AND WE'VE DONE THIS OVER THE
YEARS WHERE. WHERE THE LAW.%
DOESN'T ISN'T REALLY IMPLEMENTED
IN A WAY THAT IT SHOULD BE. WE
HAVE CALIFORNIA SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS
ENSURING A HIGH LEVEL OF
COMPETENCY WITH RESPECT TO THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE ON OUR
PUBLIC PROJECTS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. THIS RESULTS IN
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND TAXPAYERS
RECEIVING THE HIGHEST QUALITY OF
CONSTRUCTION IN FORT
UNFORTUNATELY AS I JUST SAID
DESPITE CLEAR RULES NOT ALL
CONTRACTORS IT HERE TO THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
LAW. THAT IS CLEARLY PART OF
WHAT CALIFORNIA IS ALL ABOUT IN
THIS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR THE
FINISHING CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
WHICH INCLUDES THE INSTALLATION
AND OR PURCHASE OF CARPET.
RESILIENT FLOORING SYNTHETIC
TURF OR LIGHTING FIXTURES THIS
MEASURE IMPORTANTLY REINFORCES
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE FISHING
INDUSTRY THUS ENSURING WHICH
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE ALL ALONG.
THAT THE QUALITY CONSTRUCTION OF
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS CAN
CONTINUE WHILE PROMOTING JOB BUT
A QUALITY JOBS. WITNESSES ERIC
ESPARZA THE OWNER OF MIKES
CUSTOM FLOORING AND I BELIEVE I
DON'T KNOW- MISTER SMITH SAKE TO
BEER OR- MY GREEN LEAD DIRECTOR
OF COMMUNICATIONS THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES DISTRICTS.
COUNCIL. SIXTEEN THANK YOU
MANAGER- I HAVE MISTER MISTER
GREENLEE ON THE PHONE AND ERICA
SPARSE ON THE PHONE OKAY. A GOOD
HI YOU MAY TESTIFY. HI AMERICA'S
FAR AS A WITH MY CUSTOM FLOORING
I'M ALSO A MANAGEMENT TRUSTEE ON
THE JOINT APPRENTICESHIP AND
TRAINING COMMITTEE FOR L. U.
TWENTY TWELVE FORTY SEVEN IN LOS
ANGELES- THIS BILL WOULD SOLVE A
LOT OF ISSUES I SEE IN THE
MARKET PLACE OFTEN I'VE HEARD
FROM MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT THERE THEY
HAVE THEIR FLOORING WORKS
COVERED- WHICH SEEMS STRANGE TO
ME BECAUSE I HADN'T SEEN ANY BIT
INVITES FROM THESE PUBLIC
ENTITIES IN. THREE TO FIVE
YEARS- THEY'VE GOT THIRTY TO
FORTY SCHOOL SITES. AND THEY
HAVE NO CORPORATE WORK FOR THREE
TO FIVE YEARS WELL. THEY'RE
USING ONE OF MANY- FORMS OF
PUBLIC CONTRACTING. OR
ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF PUBLIC
CONTRACTING WHICH ARE GREAT
TOOLS FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES- TO
STREAMLINED PURCHASING. ALLOWING
THEM TO SKIP THE BIDDING
PROCESS. AND SINGLE SOURCE THEIR
PURCHASES THROUGH A COVETED-
AGREEMENT. HOWEVER THESE
CONTRACTS ARE MISTER
REQUIREMENTS FOR SKILLED LABOR-
SKILLED TRANSLATOR AND HAVE NO
REQUIREMENTS FOR. REGISTERING
THESE JOBS AT THE DIR FOR
PREVAILING WAGE PURPOSES. THESE
PROVISIONS ARE PER ARE IMPORTANT
FOR MAKING OUR PUBLIC BUILDINGS.
MAKING SURE PUBLIC BUILDINGS ARE
GETTING QUALITY INSTALLATIONS.
AND THAT. THESE PROJECTS ARE
PAYING THEIR EMPLOYEES PER
CALIFORNIA LAW CONCERNING PUBLIC
PROJECTS. THANKS AGAIN FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
MIKE REALLY ON ON THE PHONE. THE
MORNING OF THE AFTERNOON
MEDICARE NUMBER TO CONNECT ME
WITH MY GROWING ON THE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR LEAD ORGANIZER FOR THE
PAYER KNOWLEDGE REYES COVER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ABOUT.
THE BILLION PEOPLE JUNE TWENTY
TO THE DEPARTMENT JOB SEARCHES
INVOLVED- OF PROCUREMENT UP AND
MAKE THEM AVAILABLE AGENCIES.
BECAUSE THEY COULD CALL. DIRECT
WHICH IS NOT TRIGGERING THIS
AWFUL WAR CAN YOU COOPER REMAINS
AND OTHER TYPES WITH OF PRIVATE
SUPPLIERS LEVERAGES STATE BY
POWER BRACKETED OF GERALD IN
PLACE SERVICES. ÍEN
METHODS YEARS THE LITTLE HAVE
OFF TO A LOCAL. WHO DO NOT HERE
TO LAWS. ARE PUBLIC. AND WHAT
THE. REPORTING CAN BE GET
REPORTER POSSIBLE TOMORROW TYPE
CONTRA GOING WITH HER AND I
THINK OPERATIONS MAYBE TRY TO
MAKE SURE BEING A CORRECTLY
OBJECTED EXPLOITATION SUFFICIENT.
BOB LITTLE LATER THEY ALSO OFTEN
PIECE WORK BREAKS FOR PAID
TRIBUTE TO THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THAT SEXUAL
VIOLATIONS WHICH ARE PREVALENT
IN THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. STOP
FORTY POINT TWO GROUPS THAT YOUR
THE COSBY FROM THE VIOLATION WE
ARE WITH ALTERNATE CONTRACTING
BUT THE- GARBAGE COLLECTION OF
CARPET RESILIENT FLOORING THE
DIRECTOR AND LIGHTING FIXTURES.
PEOPLE THREE POINT SHOOTING SURE
THAT A PERCENTAGE OF GRADUATES
STATE WHO PURCHASE PROGRAMS ARE
USED ON THE PROJECT AND THAT THE
- REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIALIZATION. BETTER
CONFIRM HIS. YOUR TIME LAPSED
YOUR SUPPORT ON IT PEOPLE CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
ON TO WITNESSES IN SOME IN ROOM
TWO HUNDRED. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD A GOOD AFTER NOON NOW I
BELIEVE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF. THIS COMMITTEE
I- NAMES ROBERT SMITH ON THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX
PLANS FOR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO STEPHANIE WANTS SOMETHING
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX AND
I HIGHLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. BOB JEROME
HAVE FOR THE INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES IN
SUPPORT. THAK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATE IF YOU COULD PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEDICARE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT FOR SB
FOURTEEN. TWENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO TO
SIGN TO WORK FOR SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO. AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH FLYING ONE OF SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I ONE OF SEVEN I THINK
YOU TOOK YOURSELF OUT IF YOU GO
INTO ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TEST FIND SUPPORT AGAIN THE WILL
MOVE ON THE LINE SIXTY. HELLO MY
GOOD MARKS ON THERE WITH THE
PRINTERS AND I LIKED REYES LOCAL
INTEREST INSTRUMENTS. WITH THE
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO. THANK
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS EARNS THE
FINAL DIRECTOR OKAY THERE'S
ABOUT AGE RESPONSE THIRTY SIX
CENTS ON CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OR ITS BE FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. I
THIRTEEN YOUR OPEN. THIRTEEN
PLEASE CALL AT. I LIKE THIRTY
ONE MORE CHANCE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TESTIFY CAN YOU HEAR ME BUT
WHAT WE CAN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRMAN INSPECTOR DAVID
CARR BUSINESS REP REPAIRS
UNIONIST LOCAL PRODUCTION NINE
AND SAN DIEGO I HEARD YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS. MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALKALINE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR OPEN. HELLO
GERMAN IS NOT WE ARE- EXPLORE
ACTIVE SUPPORT THIS BILL ON WHAT
APPEARS ALLIED TRADES DISTRICT
ALSO THIRTY SIX FOUR LAYERS
LOCAL TWELVE FORTY SEVEN AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THAT PASSED
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. WE WILL LIVE THREE
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS JULIE AND I HAD A- WITH
APPEARS ONLY CREATE BOOK FIFTY
TWO I HAD TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. TWENTY
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS DAVID THE BETA I'M
WITH THE PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES THE LOCAL THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT-
STATE BILL WORKING TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE ONE OH THREE YOU ARE OPEN.
WE PROBLEMS THE DISCOUNT THIRTY
THIRD- BUDGET BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHAD
SMITH THE TATERS AND ALLIED
TRADES INTERNATIONAL AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. MY SEVENTEEN YOU
ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS PETER SQUARE MISTER TOP OF
THIRTY SIX O'CLOCK WHAT IS SEVEN
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO AND THAT'S
BOTH THIS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. WHY MODEL FOR YOUR
OFFICE. HI MY NAME IS VINCENT
ALMOST CONTAINER GARLIC TRADED A
COUPLE THIRTY SIX FOR CURBING
LOCAL CALL FORTY SEVEN AND- GIVE
ME THE SUPPORT AND PASSED THE
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT MY
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS HENRY PAYER FOR
THE PAINTERS UNION LOCAL FIFTY
TWO ENERGY TO SUPPORT THIS THAT
THANKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL I TWENTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. MY NAME IS
STILL. IN A LOT QUICKER. SEVEN
THIRTY SIX AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK. YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE
TWENTY CALL. MY TWENTY YOUR OPEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. YES HI MY NAME'S ROBERT
WITH THE PRINTERS ARE LIKE TREES
LOCAL UNISEX. FORTY SEVEN I
HIGHLY URGENT SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY. ONE YES
THE TERM CARE YOUR LOCAL AT
THREE. THE BILL. THEY YOU NEXT
PLEASE. I LINE ONE OH NINE YOU
ARE OPEN FOR ANYBODY ELSE THE
FINAL REMINDER TO GET ONE ZERO
FOR SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO IN
SUPPORT ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ASHLEY CROWD.
UNION LOCAL THREE THIRTY EIGHT
AND I ARE YOU. FOR IT THE
FOURTEENTH TWENTY BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. ARE
THERE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP THANK YOU VERY GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION THERE IT IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION LISTED SO WHEN YOU
SEE IF ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THING NINE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU CHECK CHECK
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO- THAT'S FINE OPPOSITION.
MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WAS MUTED- YOU
SHOULD EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME OPPOSITION
FOR SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO.
AFTER NOBODY IS GIVING UP VERY
GOOD WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. MOTIONS BEEN MADE IN
SAYING NO FURTHER COMMENT CENTER
HURTS FOR YOU MAY CONCLUDE. WELL
I THINK THEY SUPPORT WAS PRETTY
OVERWHELMING AND I WITH THAT I
WILL LAST RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE FOR AN AYE VOTE VERY
GOOD. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
CAPITO I CARILLO HI NIELSEN AYE
NIELSEN AYE DURAZO TERRAZZO HI
HERTZBERGHERTZBERG HI WIENER.
FORTY ZERO FORTY ZERO WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL AND- MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT BILL. THAT BILL THIS PAST
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN WHICH IS
SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN SEVEN
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THE DATA IS STRONG WE
HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA. AT HOUSING CRISIS IS
BROADLY STALKED ABOUT ENOUGH
PLACE NOT ENOUGH PLACES FOR
PEOPLE TO LIVE IN WE'RE NOT
BUILDING AND THEN ANOTHER
HOUSING NOW WHAT IS THAT HOUSING
LOOK LIKE IS IT ALL TAX
SUBSIDIZED. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WARS ARE OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
TO HAVE HOME OWNERSHIP AND SO
THIS BILL KIND OF TURNS THE
ARGUMENT I HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S
HOUSING PLAN HERE HOW MANY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE SPENDING
OF TAX DOLLARS ON HOUSING BUT
THIS TURNS THE IDEA ON ITS HEAD.
IT BASICALLY HAS CERTAIN VERY
CORE ELEMENTS OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO FIRST WE WANT TO
INCREASE PRODUCTION WE DON'T
WANT TO JUST HAVE A PLAN THAT
JUST SAYS YOU CAN BUY YOUR
GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE BECAUSE WE
HAVE AN AD THE NEW HOUSING AND
SECONDLY WHEN SOME FAMILY THAT
COMES INTO BY THE HOUSE IT LEAKY
PIPES AND LEAKY ROOF SHE WANNA
GIVE A BRAND NEW CONSTRUCTION.
SO YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW YOU CAN HAVE A HOUSING
PLAN THAT RESULTS IN MORE
CONSTRUCTION TO YOU WANT TO HAVE
A HOUSING PLAN THAT DOESN'T COST
TAXPAYERS MONEY BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE A SURPLUS NOW THE
BOTTOM LINE IS IT DOESN'T HAVE
LAST FOR EVER THOSE OF US WHO'VE
BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME WE SEE
THAT GO UP AND DOWN. AND WE SEEN
THAT THERE'S OTHER BIG
CHALLENGES FOR GOVERNMENT TO
SPEND ITS RESOURCES CAN YOU COME
UP WITH SOMETHING WITHOUT USING
TAX DOLLARS THAT CREATE HOUSING
THIRD WE WANT TO PUT GOOD JOBS
PEPLE TO WORK AND WE WANT THIS
TO ALL BE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. AND THERE'S ALWAYS AN
ARGUMENT ABOUT THAT THE HOUSING
SECTOR WITH RESPECT TO SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE BUT WE
THINK THAT COULD HAPPEN AND WE
THINK BY HAVING A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE JUST LIKE I
SAID WITH THE LAST BILL YOU GET
BETTER QUALITY CONSTRUCTION SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A TEN
YEAR LAKE DEFECT LAW BECAUSE YOU
GOT. YOU GOT THE BETTER WORK YOU
COULD DO THINGS IN A BETTER AND
MORE INTELLIGENT WAY AND YOU'RE
NOT CREATING A SITUATION WHERE
IN LOS ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE IF
SOMEONE MAKES MINIMUM WAGE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD A TWO BEDROOM HOUSE
MAYKOP APARTMENT EXCUSE ME AND
THE LAST THING IS MOST
IMPORTANTLY I'M TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE RICH POOR DIVIDE THE
WEALTH GAP. HE KILLING OUR TO.
THE RICHER GETTING RICHER. AND
THE POOR GETTING POORER. HOME IS
WHERE TE WEALTHIEST IF YOU GIVE
PEOPLE OPPORTUNITY TO OWN A HOME
INSTEAD OF AFTER TEN YEARS OR
TWENTY YEARS ALL THEY GOT IS A
BIGGER RENT BILL. THEY MIGHT
HAVE SOME EQUITY HOW MANY
FAMILIES IN PEOPLE'S LIVES HAVE
BEEN CHANGED BECAUSE- NOT ONLY
THE IMPACTS IN THE- IN YOUR HOME
AND YOUR FAMILY. BUT TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD WEALTH. SO HOW DO YOU
STRUCTURE THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WELL OVER A YEAR WITH A
COALITION OF LABOR AND BUSINESS
AND- AND LAWYERS AND THE LIKE.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT HOW WE
WOULD DO THAT. AND WHAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU IS A TWENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR BOND. AND IT'S A
G. O. BOND DEAL MEANS GENERAL
OBLIGATION. WHAT WE DO AND WHY
DO WE HAVE A JOB ON MOST YOU'LL
BONDS MEAN THAT THE TAXPAYERS
PAY THE MONEY THIS IS CALLED THE
SELF LIQUIDATING GEO BOND WHY DO
WE GO TO THE VOTERS FOR GEO BOND
WHEN IT'S GOING TO BE PAID FOR
THE MONEY COMES FROM INVESTORS
AND IT'S GOING TO BE PAID BACK
TO INVESTORS. WE DID IT BECAUSE
BY HAVING THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YOU BY LOWER INTEREST
RATE. IF YOU BUY A LOWER
INTEREST RATE YOU REDUCE THE
COSTS IF YOU INCREASING COST
OVER HERE BECAUSE THE
CONSTRUCTION COST BECAUSE YOU'RE
PAYING A FEW DOLLARS TO FAITH
FAIR WAGES OVER HERE IF YOU CAN
REDUCE THE COST BY HAVING. THE
STATE GUARANTEE THE LOAN WHICH
IS BASICALLY WHAT THEY'RE DOING
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THE WAY THE
PROGRAM WORKS. SOMEBODY WILL GO
TO THE LOCAL BUT BUILT THE
DEVELOPER DECIDES TO OPERATE
INTO THIS PROGRAM AND THEY SAY
WE WANT TO BUILD UNDER THIS
PROGRAM THEY'LL GET SOME
BENEFITS THEY'LL GET BENEFITS ON
BY RIGHT THEY'LL GET BENEFITS
ON. ALL ON THESE SECRETS STUFF
THAT THAT SANTIAGO DID THOUGH
GET BENEFITS ON ON ON REDUCING
THE- LIABILITY FOR LLEYTON
DEFECTS AND- THEN THEY'LL GET
BENEFITS BY VIRTUE OF HAVING
SOME LOAN MONEY FOR OFFSITE
IMPROVEMENTS FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE ALL
THE IMPROVEMENTS. THEN THE CUT
WHAT IS THE CUSTOMER GET
CUSTOMER GOES TO THE BANK AND
THEY HAVE A CREDIT REPORT AND
THEY'VE GOT INCOME BECAUSE
THEY'RE WORKING FOR THE STATE OF
THE WORKING FOR WHATEVER IT MAY
BE COULD BE STAFFER HERE IN THE
BUILDING. AND THEY NOW ALL OF A
SUDDEN COULD AFFORD TO BUY THIS
BUT WHAT THEY DON'T HAVE A DOWN
PAYMENT BECAUSE YOU'RE PAYING
THE BILLS OF THE DAY THEY CAN'T
COME UP WITH THE SCRATCH TO COME
UP WITH A DOWN PAYMENT SO WE'RE
GONNA LOAN PEOPLE UP TO A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS- BASICALLY THE ONLY HAVE
TO PUT 1% DOWN AND THE REASON WE
DID ONE PERCENT. IS WE FOUND
THAT FROM ALL THE DATA IF
SOMEBODY HAS SOME SKIN IN THE
GAME SO TO SPEAK 1% OR SEVEN
FIFTY THOUSAND HOUSE THEY PUT
SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOWN
WE PUT THE OTHER HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS DOWN. AND
ALL THEY CAN GET THE HOUSE AND
THEIR MORTGAGE PAYMENT OF A
FIXED MORTGAGE MEANS THAT THAT I
COULD HAVE RENT INCREASES THE
WHOLE. WORLD CHANGES FOR THEM
THEIR LIFE CHANGED THEIR FAMILY
TREE. AND SO. WHAT HAPPENS HOW
DO YOU PAY BACK HOW DO YOU GET
THE STATE HOW DOES THE INVESTOR
GET THEIR HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS BACK. GOOD
QUESTION. THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LIEN AGAINST THE HOUSE THE
SECOND TRUSTEE. AND WHEN THE
HOUSE IS SOLD ADVERTISE TIME IS
NINE YEARS WE FIGURED OUT THE
MECHANICS IN THE MONEY. SO WITH
HOUSES SOLD THE GETS PAID BACK
THERE'S IMPUTED INTEREST OF A
COUPLE PERCENT. AND GET PAID
BACK MOST OF THE MAKE THE
MAJORITY OF THE MONEY WILL GO TO
THE- HOMEOWNER FOR INCREASE.
THERE'S NO INCREASE THEN THERE'S
NO RISK. THE A AND WE'RE
BUILDING THE NECESSARY- LEVERS
INTO THE PROGRAM TO MAKE IT
WORK. SO BOTTOM LINE IS IT'S
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. HOW DO WE
DEAL SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH THE
THORNIEST PROBLEMS TO ME THE
THORNIEST PROBLEMS IS. WE'VE GOT
TO CREATE WEALTH FOR PEOPLE.
BECAUSE WHICH JUST GETTING WORSE
AND WORSE AND WORSE THE TENSIONS
AND YOU GOT TO GIVE UP
OPPORTUNITY. IN ADDITION TO WAGE
AN OPPORTUNE TO MAKE MONEY. HOW
TO RICH PEOPLE GET RICH THEY
LIVE OFF THEIR MONEY. WHAT A
POOR PEOPLE DO THEY WORK EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND MAKE THEIR BILLS
PAID. YOU GOTTA CHANGE UP THE
ARCHITECTURE THE FINANCIAL
ARCHITECTURE. SO THAT'S WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HE TWENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR BOND. EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS GOES A LONG
PROGRAM SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS TO
DEVELOPERS WHICH GET PAID BACK
FOR OFFSIDE IMPROVEMENT SO YOU
HAVE COMMUNITIES. THAT DON'T
HAVE ALL OF THE- NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU NEED SOME
CASH TO MAKE THAT BRIDGE
FINANCING. THEY'RE STILL GONNA
BE HOMEWORK IN THIS WOMEN
LOOKING AT THE SIZING OF IT NOW.
THE OPPOSITION COMES IN AND SAYS
THIS. IS ALL THE OPPOSITION
WONDERFUL PEOPLE TO WORK WITH
FOREVER. SAYING WELL YOU'RE
GONNA FREEZE OUT THE BOND MARKET
BECAUSE- WE WANT MONEY FOR TAX
DOLLARS. FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
YEAH I GET IT. I GET IT. BUT IT
TOTALLY KILLS THE ARCHITECTURE
OF THIS DEAL BECAUSE OUR WHOLE
PURPOSE IS NOT TO GO TO
TAXPAYERS AND SAY YOU SHOULD
PAY. WE DON'T WANT IF YOU GO OUT
AND SAY WE'RE GOING TO SAY AND
SPEND FIVE BILLION OR TEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR HOUSING
BONDS. WHAT THAT MEANS IS EVERY
YEAR COULD HAVE A MORE A PAYMENT
ON YOUR GENERAL FUND THAT COMES
AHEAD OF EVERYTHING ELSE. EVERY
SALARY EVERY OTHER EXPENSE
EVERYTHING FOR FOSTER CARE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. IN AN WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO CROWD OUT OTHER IT
COSTS. AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN
WE CAN'T SELL IT IS NOT A COST
TO THE TAXPAYER. BUT IT'S REALLY
GOING TO BE A TAXPAYER DEAL. AND
SO I GET THE FACT THAT FOLKS
THAT ARE IN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUSINESS WANT TO- YOU
KNOW GIVES TAX DOLLARS AND SAY.
YOU SHOULDN'T JUST GO TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP. BUT THIS IS THE
MISSING MIDDLE THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE. TO BE
ABLE TO GET ON THE LADDER. YOU
KNOW BECAUSE THE END OF THE DAY.
I MEAN IF I HAD MY DRUTHERS
WOULD NEVER BE ANOTHER
APARTMENT. EVERYBODY WOULD OWN
EVERYBODY HAVE A CONDOMINIUM OR
A COOPER SOMETHING. OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE WEALTH BECAUSE- LASTING
A CLOSE ON THIS WHEN YOU HAVE AN
APARTMENT. YOU GOT THAT
TAXPAYERS PICKING UP THE TAB FOR
ALL THE SUBSIDIES AND GUESS WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER TWENTY YEARS. THE
RENT GOES UP WITH THE RENT GOES
UP. BIG BURDEN ON THE PERSON
ISN'T WHO'S A RENTER. SECOND
THING THAT HAPPENS IS. THE
LANDLORD GETS RICH BECAUSE THE
VALUE DEPARTMENT GOES UP. SO WE
SPENDING ALL THE MONEY WE'RE
CREATINGALL THESE COVENANTS
THEY GET TO MAKE THE DOUGH. AND
YOU KNOW THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO BUILD
EQUITY SOCIETY GOES AWAY. SO
THIS IS IT. I THINK A PRETTY
ELEGANT SOLUTION. TO FIGURING
OUT AND THEY'RE STILL HOMEWORK
AT SCHOOL GOING TO STILL WORK ON
IT. HOUSING COMMITTEE MADE A
NUMBER OF THE MINISTERS AND
MEMBERS WERE GONNA TAKE TODAY.
AND WILL WORK ON IT. AND WHAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A MEETING WITH
THE WITH THE WITH THE ADVOCATES
OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING STUFF.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO TAKE A
PREEMPTIVE STRIKE ON THAT.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW. WHAT THIS IS
SO IMPORTANT TO THE MISSING
MIDDLE IT'S SO IMPORTANT GIVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO FOLKS. WE CAN
KIDS COME OUT OF COLLEGE. IF WE
CAN DO WITH THIS WITH THE
STUDENT LOAN WHICH I'M WORKING
ON BY THE WAY. AND GET A HOUSE
AND GET ON THE LADDER TO MAKE
MONEY. SO THAT'S THAT'S THE BIG
PICTURE. WE GOT A COUPLE
WITNESSES ARE TALKING ABOUT
THIS. BUT THAT'S WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE IT'S A IT'S A HARD WORK
IT'S A HEAVY LIFT I DON'T
DISAGREE. BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S
OUR JOB FIGURED OUT FIXING. TO
GET AWAY. WITH THAT- S. ZERO
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WE
HAVE A LET FROM THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
AND MATT CALLAHAN FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP ERIN YOU MAY
PROCEED IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE. I
AM HERE- GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
KABIR ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIN LEHANE
ENDED AT FIVE PRIVILEGE TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF NEARLY HALF MILLION
MEMBERS. OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA. SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING TRADE
CURRENTLY AT SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND APPRENTICES TRAINING AT
OUR CITY ARE GOING TO CENTERS
AROUND THE STATE. THREE QUARTERS
OF THE PRODUCT OF THE PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND ONE FIVE COME FROM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FIVE
PREPARE BY MEN TO USE. YOUNG
PEOPLE COME TO THE BUILDING
TRADES PRENDAS PROGRAM FOR MANY
REASONS AND MANY DIFFERENT
GOALS. BUT WHAT WE HEAR OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AMERICA IS THAT THERE
ARE THREE MAIN THERE ARE FAMILY
SUSTAINING WAGES AND BUY. A
HOUSE SOME DAY. I KNOW HOME. THE
DREAM FOR MY IMMIGRANT
GRANDPARENTS LEMAY AND- TO THE
COUNTRY. WORK IN THE MAIL IN
FACT IN THE- AND IT VERY MUCH
REMAINS THE DREAM OF BLUE COLLAR
. ACROSS THE STATE. THESE DAYS
BUT ACTUALLY BECAUSE REAL ESTATE
PROPERTY DEVELOPERS AND
CORPORATE INVESTORS IT'S HARDER
AND HARDER TO OBTAIN. SENATOR
HERTZBERG BAIL CENTER HERTZBERG
FAILED IN A SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR
THE STREET A BILL TO HELP
WORKING FAMILIES HAVE A HOME
CALDERON TO GET OUT OF THE
ENDLESS CYCLE OF RANDY. AND I
HAVE A PLACE ULTIMATELY RETIRE
WITH DIGNITY. BUT NOVEMBER IDEA
IF THEY WERE GROUP OF WOMEN OF.
HELLO ANGELES ABOUT THIRTY. IN A
- BUT EXCEPTION ALL OF THESE
WOMEN WHO SPOKE THEIR DESIRE YOU
CAN DEFEND IT. INDEPENDENTLY OF
ANYBODY IN THE HOUSEHOLD PROVIDE
A HOME FOR THEIR FAMILIES. ONE
WOMAN REFERRED TO IT AS WELL
CATCHING A DURING. OUR OTHER IBM
OF OUR FAMILIAR MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. ALL WORKING
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP
THEM JUDGE THEIR STREAM. DO SO
IN A SOCIALLY AND MORALLY
RESPONSIBLE WAY THE VALUE THE
HARD WORK OF THE BLUE COLLAR
WORKERS WHO WILL BUILD
CALIFORNIA OUT OF ITS HOUSING
CRISIS. IT IS FOR THESE REASONS
WE SUPPORT AT BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN AT FIRST I BOTH
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MATT CALLAHAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MATT
CALLAHAN WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PARTNERS AND HOMEOWNERSHIP.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS A WEALTH
BUILDING POWER HOUSE FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
PROVIDES A PREDICTABLE MONTHLY
HOUSING EXPENSE THAT ACTUALLY
BECOMES MORE AFFORDABLE AS A
HOMEOWNERS INCOME INCREASES OVER
TIME. HOME OWNERSHIP OFFERS
BETTER HOUSING PRESERVATION WHEN
FAMILY SPACE THAT PEOPLE
FINANCIAL TIMES. PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR FUTURE FINANCIAL GOALS LIKE
RETIREMENT. AND IT IS THE MOST
DIRECT PATH TO PROVIDING
GENERATIONAL WEALTH HOME
OWNERSHIP GROWS ATTACK BASE
CREATES COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS
THE STIMULATE THE ECONOMY AND
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH HIGH OWN
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES WE SEE LOWER
CRIME RATES. AND EVEN IMPROVE
SCHOOL TEST SCORES. HOW WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
LANDSCAPING CALIFORNIA. WE SEE
THAT THE STATE'S OVERWHELMING-
INVESTMENT PROPERTY HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE HIGHLY
SUBSIDIZED RENTAL HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT GENERATE HUGE FEES
FOR DEVELOPERS AND PROPERTY
MANAGERS. DO NOT HELP WORKING
FAMILIES TAX TO PROVIDE HOUSING
THEY REALLY WANT AND THAT'S
HOMEOWNERSHIP. AS A STANCE TODAY
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA IS
AT RISK OF BECOMING AVAILABLE
ONLY TO WEALTHY ELITES. SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN GOES A LONG
WAY TO CORRECTING THIS PROBLEM
TO PROVIDE BALANCE TO THE
STATE'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STRATEGY. THE DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE FINANCING IT WILL
PROVIDE AS A CREATIVE WAY TO
FILL THE AFFORDABILITY GAP LOW
INCOME HOMEBUYERS FACE AND
EFFECTIVELY REMOVES THE SAID
THAT SAVINGS THERE. SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WILL LEVERAGE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND PRIVATE
MORTGAGE CAPITAL SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPAND THE STATE'S HOMEOWNERSHIP
HOUSING STOCK KAREGA HIGH PAYING
JOBS AND IT DOES ALL OF THIS
WITHOUT. HITTING THE TAXPAYER'S
WALLET. FOR THESE THREE WE SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND THANK
CENTER HERTZBERG CHRISLEY- SHIP
IN EXPANDING HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO.
WITNESSES TESTIFIED TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SAYING NINE IT WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO DO
IS FIND IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THE S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE ZERO. THAT'S WHY
IN SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN. RESKILLING DON'T MADAM
CHAIR VERY GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO- LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- SEE IF
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED YESSIR THANK YOU CENTER
MARKS DIVERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP ALSO
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION TO WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
NONPROFIT HOUSING. WE ACTUALLY
OF AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND OUR OPPOSITION IS
REALLY JUST FACED ON TO
PROVISIONS THE BILL WHICH
IRONICALLY THAT TRY TO CREATE
MORE AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES BY UNDERMINING
EXISTING- AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS IN BOTH
INCLUSIONARY LOCAL INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ORDINANCES AND SB THIRTY
FIVE AND SO WE DON'T THINK THESE
ARE NECESSARY TO THE CENTRE'S
OBJECTIVES OF THE BILL AND THEY
ARE UNDERMINE AGAIN THOSE OF
INCESSANT INTEROPERATION. THE
ISSUE THE SENATOR HERTZBERG
MENTIONS ALSO GREAT CONCERN TO
US I THINK THE BUILDING ON WHAT
THE CONSULTANT IS WRITTEN THE
ANALYSIS I THINK THE IDEA THAT
THESE ARE SELF LIQUIDATING BONTA
SOMEWHAT- UNLIKELY- MOST OF
THESE LOANS WOULD BE PAID BACK
FOR AT LEAST FIFTEEN OR LONGER
YEARS IT'LL BE A LOT OF GENERAL
FUND GOING OUT IN THE MEANTIME-
AND WE'VE NEVER DONE A GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND ET ALONE ONE OF
THIS SIZE IT FOR HOUSING IS NOT
BEEN BALANCED IN ITS APPROACH
LOOKING AT VARIOUS DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES SO WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF OWNERSHIP. ONE BIG
THAT VERY VERY CLEAR WE ARE VERY
SUPPORT OF THIS SENATORS EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS WHO DO
THINK OF BOND OF THIS SIZE ON
THE BALLOT HOPEFULLY WILL BE A
BALANCED ONE AMONG VARIOUS
HOUSING NEEDS INCLUDING PEOPLE
WHO ARE HOMELESS ON THE STREETS
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME RENTERS TO.
ADD ARE SEVERELY COST BURDENED
IN PAYING FOR HOUSING SO WE HAVE
A RIFLE HOUSING NEEDS WE LIKE TO
MEET WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
CENTER HERTZBERG ON THAT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SEE-
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. THING
NINE A MOVING TO THE TELE. LINE
MR MADHUR IF YOU Q. WITNESSES
WANT TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION WHO- SB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIVE
EIGHT ZERO FOR OPPOSITION TO SB. FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME VERY
VERY GOOD WILL BRING THIS BILL
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR
WIENER I THANK YOU MANAGEMENT
SURE I'D- SUPPORTED THIS BILL
AND- HOUSING COMMITTEE WITH
AMENDMENTS AND ALL SUPPORTED
AGAIN TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL- I YOU KNOW OUR
TIME WILL BE CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS- WITH THE HAUSER'S-
I WILL SAY I DON'T- FIVE. YOU
KNOW I HAVE NO. I DON'T OBJECT
TO MIDDLE INCOME FOCUSED-
HOUSING PROGRAMS LIKE THIS- YOU
KNOW IS. UNITING THE OPPOSITION
POINT IS- IS VALID AND THAT WE
HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES AND GREAT
NEEDS OF VARIOUS INCOME LEVELS
THAT'S ALWAYS THE- THE TOUGH
PART OF IT AND- YOU KNOW IT'S
AND I'M NOT SEEN AS A RIGHT OR
WRONG ANSWER IT'S JUST REALLY.
REALLY HARD BECAUSE THIS SOCIETY
IS REALLY D. PRIORITIZE THE
PRIORITIZED. HOUSING SUBSIDIES
WE USED TO BUILD ALL SORTS OF
PUBLIC HOUSING MASSIVE
INVESTMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THAT YOU KNOW
ENDED FORTY YEARS AGO- AND WE'VE
BEEN PICKING UP THE PIECES EVER
SINCE SO I HOPE WE ARE AT ONE
POINT ACTUALLY GOT. MASSIVE
FEDERAL INVESTMENT HOUSING LIKE
WE USED TO HAVE- PASSAGE WANTED
TO DO ONE SAYS I ALIVE SUPPORT
HOMEOWNERSHIP- PROGRAMS- RENTING
IS ALSO IMPORTANT I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY FOR YOU KNOW OUR
LOWEST INCOME RESIDENTS IT'S PER
THERE ARE. PEOPLE WHO IT'S NOT.
REALISTIC AT LEAST AT NUMBER
PRESENT WAY FOR THEM TO OWN. BUT
BUT RENTAL ACTUALLY I DIDN'T
DOES PLAY. US IMPORTANT ROLE IN
AN EFFICIENT HOUSING MARKET
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT YOU'RE NOT IN A POSITION
THE OWNER AT THAT MAKES NO SENSE
FOR THEM. TO OWN- RENTING HAVING
THAT NOT IS THE ONLY THING
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS VERY. IMPORTANT
RENTING IS VERY IMPORTANT. A
TERMS OF- MOBILIT FOR PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO RELOCATE TO DIFFERENT
PLACES MEMBER THE NOT READY TO
SETTLE DOWN- THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE JUST NOT A PLACE TO LIVE
WHERE THEY WANT TO MAKE THAT
LONG TERM COMMITMENTS ARE PEOPLE
NEED THE FLEXIBILITY. TWO METERS
AROUND OUR OWN. ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS NOW. I'M SO SORRY ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS NOW IS THAT
BECAUSE OF A MASSIVE HOUSING
SHORTAGE WE ARE NOT GIVING
PEOPLE THE OPTION TO OWN BECAUSE
IT'S TOO IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE SO
THEY ARE RENTERS WHO WANT TO
OWN. WE SHOULD GIVE THEM THAT
ABILITY. WELL RECOGNIZING THAT
RENTING IS STILL VERY IMPORTANT
. SO I WILL BE AN AYE VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU FOR THE WATER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. CENTER DRIVE YEAH- I
KNOW THE- AUTHORS EVEN EXPRESSED
RIGHT BUT THE GOAL IS. WE GOT TO
GET MORE PEOPLE TO GET. A
GENERATIONAL WEALTH- SO AND I
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE IN THAT-
SIMILAR TO WHAT- CENTER WIENER
SAID. HOW DO WE HOW DOES THIS
HELP. THE ISSUE OF SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO.
TAKE EVEN THAT LOAN RIGHT BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT LOAN TO
THEM HOW DOES THIS HELP. THE
ENORMOUS CRISIS OF PEOPLE WHO
CAN BARELY HOLD ON- THEY WOULD
DREAM OF THE DAY THAT THEY COULD
. ASK FOR A LOAN SOMEWHERE AND
BE ABLE TO PAY IT BACK SO I IT.
IT SOME IT'S AN IMPORTANT I SEE
IT IS IMPORTANT PIECE BUT WITH
WHAT WE'RE FACING RIGHT NOW HOW
DO YOU. HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT WELL IT IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IS TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT CON LIKE
WE DO IN RENTAL HOUSING IF
SOMEONE SAY COMES IN DEVELOPER.
HAS HAS A HUNDRED UNITS WE COULD
DO IS SET ASIDE FOR MORE
AFFORDABLE PEOPLE AND BASICALLY
THE OTHER PEOPLE ARE GONNA KILL
HIGHER PRICE TO GET THERE WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT BUT WE
CAN'T SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM. ONE
OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE'VE
GOTTEN REASON RENTS ARE GOING UP
SO HIGH AS WE HAVE A SUPPLY AND
DEMAND PROBLEM SO HOW DO WE-
INCREASE AND INCENTIVIZE THE-
SUPPLY SIDE RIGHT HOW DO WE
INCREASE PRODUCTION ALL THE
NUMBERS TALKING ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF MILLION THREE HAVE ME
WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS. OF WHAT
WE NEED IN THAT DEFICIT THAT'S
CAUSING RISING COSTS FOR
EVERYBODY SO LOOK CLEARLY I
THINK WHAT SENATOR WINNERS IT'S
CORRECT I OVERSTATE MY CASE.
WHICH IS FINE TERMS ARE BETTER
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY I
WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
WEALTH I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR SOCIETY OF PEOPLE
BUILD WEALTH THERE ARE NEEDS
OTHERWISE BUT TO THE EXTENT
FOLKS ARE ARE POOR AND WANT TO
BE ABLE TO. GET SOMETHING AND
BUILD WEALTH WE GOT TO MAKE THE
ECONOMICS WORK SO NO IT DOESN'T
SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM BUT WHAT IT
DOES DO IN MY THINKING IS THA
INSTEAD OF THE TAX DOLLARS
PAYING FOR EVERYTHING ALL THE
TIME TO SO MANY DEMANDS WE'VE
GOT TO BALANCE IT OUT. WE'VE GOT
TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR A
LEG UP FOR PEOPLE AT THE SAME
TIME WEGOT TO PROVIDE THE
SAFETY NET ALL THE OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE ALONG
THE CONTINUUM I'M NOT TRYING TO
SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS. I'M
TRYING TO SOLVE ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS AND I WOULD SUGGEST TO
YOU THAT THIS COLLATERAL
BENEFITS BRIEFLY IN THIS IF YOU
HAVE HAVING A BUNCH MORE HOUSING
COSTS WHAT YOU INCREASE PROPERTY
TAX INCREASE THE PROPERTY TAX
INCREASE MONEY. TO BE ABLE TO
PAY FOR SO SAFETY THAT ISSUES
YOU CREATE JOBS WHICH THEN
CREATE. CONSTRUCTION JOBS 74%
ECONOMIC FEEDBACK AFFECT HUGE
IMPACTS THE HELP BRIDES
EVERYBODY ALONG THE PROCESS SO.
YOU GOTTA BUILD THE MONEY YOU
GOTTA MAKE WORK DOM KLAY. AND
YOU'RE RIGHT. SOLVE ALL THOSE
THOSE ARE. BUT I THINK IT A LOT
OF OTHER BENEFITS AND- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH A TEN GAUGE
THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF FINANCE.
AND HIS TEAM AND WE'LL GET BACK
TO PUT OUT A REPORT THAT TALKS
ABOUT. ALL OF THE JOBS ALL OF
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT ALL OF THE
BENEFITS FROM A PROGRAM LIKE
THIS IN TERMS OF ITS- ITS
BROADER SENSE. AND A DEAL. THE
POINT THAT WAS MADE WITH RESPECT
TO THE SIZE OF BONDS WE DID TOO
I DID A TWENTY FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLAR BOND. AB SIXTEEN
AND I THINK 200-022-0004 FOR
SCHOOLS WE'VE DONE BIG BONDS. A
IN TERMS OF THE SIZE OF THE
BONDS BUT WE ARE GOING TO MEET
WITH THE COMMUNITY WE ARE GOING
TO SIT DOWN AND TALK TO HIM.
WE'VE TALKED ALREADY REACHED OUT
TO HIM TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
MAKE THIS WORK BUT IT IS THOSE
QUESTIONS ARE LARGER SOCIETAL
QUESTIONS. OF WHAT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT. ON BUT THIS IS ONE
OF KIND OF THE MISSING ELEMENTS.
TO TRY TO GIVE PEOPLE. THIS
GENERATIONAL WEALTH. IN ANY WAY
THAT WE CAN I THINK THAT SOLVES
A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER ISSUES AND
WITH THAT. I USE THAT AS MY
CLOTHES. IS THAT THAT SOUNDS
AMAZING FOR THE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT-
IS THERE A MOTION. VOTE 8% OF
MAJOR MOVE OKAY VERY GOOD- AS A
MANAGER WIENER MOVE TO BELL. THE
BILL IS DUE PASS AS- THE VOTE
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS CAPITO HI CAFIERO
HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI DURAZO.
DORADO HI HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG
HI WIENER. WIENER HI. FIVE DAYS
A THE MOTION PASSES.
THAT WE WERE NEXT GONNA TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH IS
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR DURAZO. SENATOR EYES OF
THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AT AND MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR ALL OF HER.
INVOLVEMENT AND ASSISTANCE ON
THE COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THESE AMENDMENTS
EXCEPT THE ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE TWO
THAT- GO INTO PAGE THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS. IS B. TWELVE TWENTY
SIX IS A BILL THAT WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO MEETING THE
STATE'S ZERO EMISSION GOALS BY
FACILITATING A PUBLIC PRIVATE
NONPROFIT PARTNERSHIPS THROUGH
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
STRUCTURE. TO CREATE GREEN-
CREATE AND COLLABORATE ON GREEN
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS WE ARE
OF THE STATE IS A LEADER IN THE
GLOBAL EFFORT TO ADDRESS.
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDING
AMBITIOUS EMISSIONS REDUCTION
GOALS IN ORDER TO MEET THESE
GOALS. THIS OKAY- IN ORDER TO
MEET THESE GOALS GOALS A STATE
IS FOCUSED ON REDUCING
TRANSPORTATION BASED EMISSIONS
WHICH ARE AMONG THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT SOURCES. THESE
EFFORTS HAVE INCLUDED
ESTABLISHING CLEAN ENERGY
ELECTRIC VEHICLE PROGRAMS TO
INCENTIVIZE THE PURCHASE OF ZERO
EMISSION CARS OUGHT IN ADDITION
GOVERN NEWSOM'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
SET A GOAL OF A 100% ZERO
EMISSIONS NEW VEHICLES BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. IN ADDITION TO
PRIVATE VEHICLES. THE STAYS
TAKEN STEPS TO BUILD OUT A GREEN
TRUCK PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE CALIFORNIA JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY LAW AUTHORIZES
TO MORE PUBLIC AGENCIES BY
CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENT TO JOINTLY
EXERCISE ANY POWER COMMENT TO
THE CONTRACTING PARTIES.
LEGISLATION HAS EXPANDED THE
ABILITY FOR PRIVATE PARTIES TO
BECOME PART OF SUCH AGREEMENTS
INCLUDING ENTITIES SUCH AS
HOSPITALS NONPROFITS AND
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING SERVICES
TO PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THERE IS A NEED TO
FOSTER COLLABORATION AT THE KEY
WORD AMONGST WILLING AND ABLE
ENTITIES TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
GOODS AND SERVICES FOR WHICH
THERE ARE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
NONPROFIT AND ENTITIES ENGAGED.
IN INNOVATIVE AND- SOME
INNOVATION AND PUBLIC AGENCIES
SEEKING TO BUILD OUT
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS BILL WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO BUILDING OUT-
GREEN PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. OF
BY FACILITATING THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO COME TOGETHER
COLLABORATE AND- ON THESE
PROJECTS WITH ME ARE HILLARY
NORTON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FAST
LINK DTLA AND THEN WE GET WORD
THE CLIMATE RESULT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BOTH OF YOUR WITNESS
OR WITNESSES ARE ON THE PHONE SO
WE'LL START WITH THE HILLARY
NORTON. HERY NORTON ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. IT'S BEEN A LONG
HEARING SO. MISTER MODERATED
COULD YOU CHECK TO SEE IF
HILLARY- NORTON IS ON THE LINE.
I'M ON THE LINE VERY GOOD THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. YES I AM VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE IMPORTANT
SENATOR DROPPED OFF HI AND-
EXCITED TO SUPPORT EVERYTHING
THAT SHE HAD HIGHLIGHTED BECAUSE
I AM STEPPING OUT RIGHT NOW ALL
OF OUR MEETING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HOUSING AND
REDEVELOPMENT. SHOULDN'T BECAUSE
WE ARE TALKING VERY. RIGHT THIS
SECOND ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO TO
PROVIDE MORE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
ACTION GOALS. YES A VERY
IMPORTANT EFFORT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN DELIVER THESE
PROJECTS INCLUDE IMPORTANT
NONPROFIT AND HAVE THESE TOOLS
IN THE TOOLBOX. JUST AT A TIME
WHEN THEY ARE FEDERAL FUNDS AND
STATE FUNDS TO MAKE THE PROJECT
HAPPEN PLEASE PASS THIS BILL SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAD YET ANOTHER WAY THAT WE CAN
GO AFTER THE FUNDS THAT ARE
NECESSARY. TO CLEAN THE AIR TO
SERVE EQUITY COMMUNITIES AND TO
DELIVER. THE EMISSION IN FOR. ON
TIME ON BUDGET IN A WAY THAT
HELPS EVERYBODY I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR DIRECTOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. AND THE SUPPORT SHE
IS GETTING TO CREATE MORE OF
THESE PROJECTS SO THAT WE CAN
CREATE MORE UNION JOBS AS WELL
AS DELIVER THEM IN WAYS. THAT
ARE GOING TO BE. LEADING THE
NATION IN HOW WE CAN DELIVER
ZERO EMISSION. INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WE'D LIKE TO HEAR
FROM NGK WHERE TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURTLE EURO AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE. MY NAME
IS AND WE CAN WORK AROUND THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR CLIMATE
RESULT NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WHO FOR THE PAST DECADE HAS BEEN
WORKING TO ADAPT LOS ANGELES THE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND PROTECTING
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
FROM OR AIR QUALITY AND WE-
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR GRASSO'S
BILL SB TWELVE TWENTY SIX IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THERE ARE LIMITED RESOURCES THAT
HINDER THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
FACILITATE THE DEVELOPMENT
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION OF
ZERO EMISSION SYSTEM. LET ALONE
APPLY FOR GRANTS TO DO SO THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THEM TO COME TO
THE TABLE BY ALLOWING FOR
PRIVATE PUBLIC NONPROFIT
PARTNERSHIPS WILL PROVE
MOBILITY- QUALITY AND GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS COLLABORATIVE
COLLABORATIVELY. SB TWELVE ME
SIX BUCKS THE STUFF I'D LIKE TO
MAKE THREE POINTS FIRST CURRENT
LAW COULD NOT ALLOW ME TO
COMPLETE THEM BUT WITH NON
PROFITS TO FORM. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF FACILITATING THE REMISSIONS.
SYSTEMS WHICH MIXES AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PUBLIC FUNDING
MECHANISM. SOCKET THE STATE IS
WOEFULLY SHORT OF ITS GOAL TO
MEET AIR QUALITY AND GRIEF
GREENHOUSE. GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS THAT. ANOTHER TOOL IN
THE TOOL. THAT WILL PROMOTE
AMBITIOUS EMISSIONS REDUCTION.
THIRD EIGHT TWELVE TWENTY THREE.
ALLOWS THE TO ADDRESS THE MOST.
SOURCES OF MISSION IN THE TRASH
. SECTOR I BUILDING OUT BRING
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO LOWER
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
REDUCING THE COMES. AND IMPROVE
ACCESS AND- OF OUR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
ON THIS MATTER AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE ON SB. TWELVE
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
NEXT TIME TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
WORKED TO TURN TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB
TWELVE TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TWELVE
TWENTY SIX TO PASS BY IN SUPPORT
. AND OUR FIRST ARTIST BUT WILL
BE LYING SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARKETS THAT WHILE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE
WILL THE LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DEBBIE CAN CON ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES CLEANTECH
INCUBATOR OVERCROWDING IN
SUPPORT OF THE STUFF. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT THANK YOU
MEDICARE THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR SB TWELVE TWENTY
SIX ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS CHRIS WHAT THE
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION WE
ARE REPORT OF SB TWELVE TWENTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT. WE HAVE A ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS- THERE NOR THE
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME I'M SURE VERY GOOD- WILL
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION THERE ARE
THERE ARE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SO WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. NOW'S
YOUR CHANCE SINGMAN WILL MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE SEED IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU- TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE
ZERO. TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWELVE TWENTY SIX.
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. VERY GOOD WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS THERE
IS A MOTION THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE. ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGERVERY GOOD- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS CAPITO I
CABALLERO HI NIELSEN HI NIELSEN
HI COROZZO HI TERRAZZO HI
HERTZBERG. WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
BORDER ZERO THE MOTION PASSES-
FORTY ZERO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO THE LAST ITEM. MAKE A
TRANSITION HERE.
OUR LAST THE BILL TODAY IS THE
CHAIRS BILL. HE WILL PRESENT TO
THE COMMITTEE TODAY. ARE YOU
READY TO GO I DON'T CARE I AM
READY. PLEASE PROCEED ON YOUR
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU MEMBERS AND- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB FOURTEEN FORTY NINE
THE UNINCORPORATED AREA
ANNEXATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE IN THIS BILL ON THIS
BILL AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE FOUR
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. WHAT
THE STATE THERE ARE MANY
URBANIZED INHABITED AREAS IN THE
COUNTY AND INCORPORATED AREAS
THAT ARE SURROUNDED BY
INCORPORATED CITY RESIDENTS.
THESE AN INCORPORATED AREAS HAVE
NO LOCAL REPRESENTATION BUT
INSTEAD ARE GOVERNED BY THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
THESE AREAS ESPECIALLY IMPORTED
THIS ADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES THE
LEVEL OF BASIC INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SERVICES IS MINIMAL IF IT
EXISTS AT ALL. TO ILLUSTRATE THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL I ASK YOU TO
PUT YOURSELF IN THE SHOES OF
SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN A POOR
RURAL AN INCORPORATED AREA.
IMAGINE A PARENT WALKING THEIR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL ONE DAY AFTER
A HEAVY NIGHT OF RAIN. BECAUSE
THE COMMUNITY LACKS PROPER
SIDEWALKS AND STORM DRAINAGE THE
FAMILY IS FORCED TO WALK IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ROAD IN ORDER TO
AVOID FLOODED- MANY AREAS ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD THE TYPICALLY
SERVE AS PEDESTRIAN PATHS. THIS
IS THE REALITY FOR MANY PEOPLE
LIVING IN UNINCORPORATED AREAS
AT NIGHT I'VE SEEN IT I'VE BEEN
IN THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS- AFTER A
RAINY DAY AND- I WAS SHOCKED. TO
SEE PARENTS WALKING THEIR
CHILDREN DOWN THE MIDDLE OF THE
STREET. BECAUSE HE'S COMMUNITIES
DO NOT HAVE A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO PROVIDE SERVICES THEY MUST
MAKE DO WITH WHAT LITTLE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE
EXISTS. THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE PROVIDED WITHIN
A CITY VERSES WITHIN AN
UNINCORPORATED AREA IS EVEN MORE
NOTICEABLE IN THE AREA HAPPENS
TO BE FULLY SURROUNDED BY CITIES
BOUNDARIES. CREATING AN
UNINCORPORATED ISLAND. IN MANY
CASES LEADING RIGHT UP TO THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE ISLAND THERE
WILL BE PAVED ROADS SIDEWALKS
CURBS GUTTERS AND STREET LIGHTS
ONLY TO STOP. IMMEDIATELY UPON
ENTERING THE BOUNDARIES AT THE
END INCORPORATED HIGHLAND. AND
TO CONTINUE ON AGAIN WITH CITY
SERVICES AFTER EXITING THAT THAT
ISLAND. WELL EXISTING LAW
PREVENTS THE CITY FROM
LEAPFROGGING OVER AN
INCORPORATED AREAS WHEN
EXPANDING THEIR BORDERS TODAY.
THE INCORPORATED ISLANDS CREATED
FROM YEARS OF CITIES PICKING AND
CHOOSING WHICH AREAS THEY WISH
TO ANNEX REMAINS. THIS IN PART
IS DUE TO THE COST TO BUILD AND
CONNECT THE COMMUNITY THE CITY
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH CREATED A
DISINCENTIVE FOR SISTER CITIES
TO PURSUE ANNEXATION. THAT'S WHY
I'VE INTRODUCED SB FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE THIS YEAR TO
ENCOURAGE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
JOINTLY PURSUE ANNEXATIONS OF
THESE UNINCORPORATED AREAS AND
PROVIDE THE BASIC NEEDS THAT
MOST PEOPLE TAKE FOR GRANTED. AS
A WAY TO ELIMINATE THESE ISLANDS
SPECIFICALLY SB FOURTEEN FORTY-
WELL AT FOURTEEN FORTY NINE WILL
CREATE A NEW GRANT PROGRAM
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. TO
PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE THROUGH A
MATCHING GRANT PROGRAM FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES- WHO ANNEX
UNINCORPORATED AREAS FOR
PURPOSES OF FUNDING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS RELATED
TO HEALTH AND SAFETY. SUCH AS
SEWER SERVICE SIDEWALKS CURBS
STORMWATER MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS
WITH AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY AND
COMMITTEE OPR WILL BE REQUIRED
TO PRIORITIZE GRANTS FOR
ANNEXATION OF DISADVANTAGED
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES AND A
WORK WITH SPECIFIC STAKEHOLDERS
THAT REPRESENT CITIES AND
COUNTIES. AND THE LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION TO DEVELOP
THE PROGRAM. HERE WITH ME AND
COMMITTEE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS CHRISLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. MR LEE
PLEASE CONFIRM. GOOD AFTERNOON
BY STERN NIELSEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES HERE TODAY IN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT- I KNOW
WE'VE HAD A LONG HEARING SO I'LL
TRY TO LIMIT MY ENTHUSIASM AND
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF BUT I DO
REALLY LIKE THIS BILL AND ONE OF
THE REASONS I LIKE IT SO MUCH AS
I THINK BACK TO MY TIME IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WORKING WITH THE
COUNTY WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES
THAT WOULD DIRECTLY BENEFIT FROM
PROGRAM LIKE THIS I THINK ABOUT
A MOBILE HOME PARK SURROUNDED ON
THREE SIDES BY A CITY AND ON ONE
SIDE BY ACTUALLY THE NEIGHBORING
COUNTY HUGE PROBLEMS WITH
SERVICES EVEN JUST GETTING THE
SHERIFF TO GO OUT THERE BECAUSE
OF THE PHYSICAL ISOLATION I
THINK AOUT A COMMUNITY THAT'S
LOCATED JUST ACROSS THE STREET
FROM A CITY BUT DOESN'T HAVE
WATER AND SEWER SERVICE. EXCEPT
FOR VERY LIMITED AND-
SUBSTANDARD SYSTEM THESE ARE THE
TYPES OF COMMUNITIES IN THE
TYPES OF DISPARITIES THAT SB
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE WILL HELP TO
REMEDY AND SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT WHY DO
WE HAVE SOME OF THESE
DISCREPANCIES SO MANY OF THESE
AREAS MAY HAVE BEEN BUILT BEFORE
TODAY'S MODERN STANDARDS FOR
IMPROVEMENTS THEY MIGHT OF USE
LOOPHOLES LIKE FOR BY BORING OR
A PARCEL MAP OR I'D ANTIQUATED
SUBDIVISION TO GET AROUND. THE
BUILT BUILDING ENVIRONMENT IN
TERMS OF PRODUCING THOSE
SIDEWALKS AND OTHER OFFSITE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE OFTEN
NEEDED A LOT OF THE
INCORPORATORS AREAS LACK THE TAX
BASE THEY GET A SMALL SHARE OF
THE PROPERTY TAX THE AREAS THAT
HAVE A LOT OF SALES TAX ARE
USUALLY THE FIRST ONES TO GET
ANNEXED AND SO WHERE YOU
TYPICALLY SEE A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SERVICE IN THE UNINCORPORATED
ZONE IS WHERE PEOPLE HAVE VOTED
TO TAX THEMSELVES ARE. FORMER
SPECIAL DISTRICT TO PROVIDE A
HIGHER LEVEL OF SERVICE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT THEY'RE
REALLY COMPETING AGAINST EVERY
OTHER USE OF GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE HAPPENING
AT THE COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PUBLIC SAFETY ETCETERA.
SO REALLY SMETIMES THE BEST
OPTION FOR THESE COMMUNITIES IS
ANNEXATION INTO THE CITY BUT WHY
ISN'T THAT HAPPENING SOONER
CABALLERO DIGNIFIED ONE OF THE
KEY ISSUES WHICH IS THE COST OF
BRINGING THAT INFRASTRUCTURE UP
TO THE SAME LEVEL AS THE CITY'S.
GOING AN EXAMPLE FOR STANNIS
COUNTY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND. DOLLARS
PER MILE OF SIDEWALK
IMPROVEMENTS AND CITIES AND
COUNTIES ALREADY FACE HUGE
DEFICITS FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THIRTY SEVEN
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
UNFUNDED NEEDS TO MAINTAIN OUR
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS OVER THE
NEXT DECADE. AND TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR COMPLETE
STREETS COMPONENTS LIKE
SIDEWALKS DRAINAGE IN EXACTLY
THE TYPES OF THEM STRUCTURE SB
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE WITH SUPPORT
. I'M WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHORED MAKE SURE
THE INCENTIVE STRUCTURE IN SOME
OF THE SPECIFICS OF THE BILL GET
THIS RIGHT BECAUSE THAT. THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE IT
REALLY WORKS IN PRACTICE BUT
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT AND ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER. HERE PRESENT THE
TESTIFY SIR THANKS EVEN ACROSS
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. LEAGUE OF CITIES YOU
SAID. YES SIR OKAY THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS. A AND- DO WE HAVE
ANY- ON ON THE LINE. MODERATOR
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS KILLING
OUT ALL RIGHT. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION BUT WHY DON'T YOU
INQUIRE OPERATOR WE'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE ANY BUT- WOULD
YOU INQUIRE. AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY AT THIS TIME
INTO OPPOSITION R. FOR
OPPOSITION. ON S. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO. SOUNDS LIKE
THERE ARE NONE A MEDICARE WOULD
GOING UP WITH PART PARDON. I AYE
SKEWS ME I WAS JUST SAYING
NOBODY IS KILLING US THAT'S WHAT
I FIGURED THE MAN CARE DO WANT
TO WISH TO DO GOOD VEHICLES FOR
SENATE BECAUSE THE CENTER WE ARE
NOT EXCUSE ME NO PROBLEM- FIVE
FOR SO I MOVED THE BILL- I MEAN
THIS IS A REALLY GOOD IDEA
GIVING- COUNTIES ARTISTICALLY
GIVING CITIES MORE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES. AND INCENTIVES TO OUR
CORPORATION OUR TO AN EXCUSE ME-
OF COURSE ANNEXATION IS ALWAYS-
COMPLICATED AND THERE THE
SITUATIONS THAT YOU DESCRIBED
WITH HER VERY VERY REAL- THERE
ARE OTHER- MORE POLITICIZED
ASPECTS OF MY- I NEVER HAD TO-
YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
ANNEXATION- BEING IN A CITY IN A
COUNTY THAT WAS COMBINED BUT-
ONES. I WAS ELECTED TO THE
SENATE THANK YOU REPRESENT
UNINCORPORATED AREA AND A
CEMETERY COUNTY- BROUGHT MORE
WHICH IS IF YOU LOOK AT A MAP IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S PART OF DALY
CITY BUT IT'S NOT AND THERE'S
BEEN THE RECESSION LEGISLATION
DECADES AGO BY- THEM CENTER
CLINT COP TO BAN DALY CITY FROM
ANNEXING. BROADMOOR DALY CITY AS
A TIMES AND NEXT BECOME THE
LUCRATIVE TAX BASS COMMERCIAL
AREAS ABROAD MORE BUT DOESN'T
WANT THE RESIDENTIAL AREAS AND
BROADMOOR HAS ITS OWN POLICE
COMMISSION THEIR SYSTEMS SELVES
ARE PENSION LIABILITIES USE IS
ALWAYS VERY COMPLICATED BUT
OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO
ENCOURAGE- ANNEXATION THE
SUPPORT OF SOME HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. AND THE QUESTION
ALSO- THANK YOU SENATOR- IT IS
STILL WITH. THIS TO ENCOURAGE I
JUST WANT TO CLEAR THAT THE
GRANT. DOESN'T READ THEM TO. THE
B. M. BUT THAT IS- IT'S WHILE IT
. DON'T WORRY ABOUT WHILE I.
CONSIDERED REQUIRING IT BECAUSE
MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
HAVE REALLY BEEN ABANDONED TO
THEIR OWN DEVICES THERE ON SEPT
SIX WHEN THEY'RE SEWER RIGHT
DOWN AT THE END OF THE STREET-
THEY SOME OF THEM ARE ON WELLS
STILL WHEN THEY COULD HOOK INTO
THE WATER SYSTEM AND- NOT HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT THEIR WELLS- AND
THEN THERE'S THE CURB GUTTER
SIDEWALK THE DRAINAGE ISSUES-
THIS. IS VOLUNTARY- THIS WILL
CREATE. THE REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE NEIGHBORS TO
UNITE AND TO GO TO THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY AND TO SAY WE WANT
THIS I'VE MET WITH A NUMBER OF
NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS AND THIS IS
THEIR NUMBER ONE ISSUE IS THAT.
WE HAVE REALLY BAD SERVICE THIS
THE SHERIFF IS RARELY IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD BECAUSE THEY'RE OUT
IN THE- IN THE HINTERLANDS- AND
WHEN WE HAVE A PROBLEM WE CALL
CITY POLICE. WHEN THEY MOVE INTO
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS THEY DON'T
KNOW THAT IT'S A COUNTY
INCORPORATED BECAUSE IT LOOKS
THE SAME AND AT NIGHT. IF YOU
DRIVE ITO THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
IT'S PITCH DARK AND YOU CAN SEE
THREE BLOCKS DOWN THE ROAD YOU
CAN SEE THE LIGHTS. STARTING AND
A BLOCK THIS WAY AND SEE THE
LIGHTS AND SO THEY'RE REALLY-
LEFT- YOU END UP WITH BURNED OUT
HOUSES- A LOT OF TRASH BEING
ACCUMULATING IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
BECAUSE THERE'S NO LIGHTS
THERE'S NO ACTIVITY- TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE SO THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT IS SO THIS IS- TO
ALLOW THEM TO. APPLY FOR THE
GRANTS TO. DO THE THINGS THAT.
SHOULD BE DONE THAT'S CORRECT
BUT ULTIMATELY. THEY THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE AND I GUESS THE IDEA
IS THAT IT'S AN INCENTIVE THIS
IS THE CARROT BEFORE WE GO IN
WITH A STICK. SO MANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO COMMENT. AND
WE HAVE A MOTION THE NEW WANNA
GIVE A CLOSURE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS OKAY. WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SIR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS CAPITO. CAPITO HI
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI DURAZO
DORADO HI HERTZBERG. WIENER AYE
WIENER I. FOUR ZERO WE HAVE THE
VOTES DO YOU WANT TO PUT IT ON
CALL THE MANAGER. NO I SENATOR
HERTZBERG HAS LEFT OKAY FOR
TODAY SO GO AHEAD. AND SO THAT
BILL IS OUT WILL TAKE UP THE
BILLS THANK YOU SIR- WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP THE BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN PLACED ON CALL.
WE PLACED A NUMBER OF BILLS ON
CALL WHEN IT- CALL ITEM NUMBER
ONE ON THE AGENDA S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SENATOR WIENER WIENER HI. FIVE
DESERVE ALL. THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO ZERO. I'M GONNA CALL
ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS S. B.
EIGHT NINE SEVEN BY SENATOR
RIGHT CASKEY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARE THERE ARE NO
ABSENT MEMBERS VERY GOOD- AND
THAT WAS. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO.
NOT BAD BILL IS OUT AS WELL AND
THEN- ITEM NUMBER NINE ON THE
AGENDA SP FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI. THAT THE BILL
IS OUT FIVE TWO ZERO. VERY GOOD
. THANK THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND
THE STATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE IS
ADJOURNED. BETTER CARE.